bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
public sénat je vous propose ce matin de
revoir la séance qui s'est déroulée hier
soir au sénat le sénat examine en ce
début de semaine le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif pour 2013 hier
dans l'hémicycle le secrétaire d'état au
budget christian eckert a assuré que la
politique d'assainissement
d'assainissement budgétaire du
gouvernement porté ses fruits faux lui a
répondu le président ump de la
commission des finances philippe marini
pour qui au contraire le déficit de
l'état s'aggrave il l'a même philippe
parini accusé le gouvernement de pas
citer dans la présentation des comptes
publics alors je vous rappelle que ce
projet loi de finances rectificatif et
bien prévoit 4 milliards d'économies
supplémentaires pour cette année dont
1,6 milliard qui concerneront
directement le budget de l'état ce texte
comporte également des allègements
d'impôt sur le revenu pour les ménages
les plus modestes ainsi que le
remplacement de l'écotaxe par une taxe
de transit pour les poids lourds donc
direction tout de suite l'hémicycle du
sénat pour revoir la séance de nuit sur
ce projet loi de finances rectificatif
très bonne journée à tous sur notre
antenne mes chers collègues le sujet est
révélateur des contradictions qui
existent
au sein du parti socialiste d'abord
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
vous me permettez de commenter
l'amendement du rapporteur général chers
collègues
oui sans doute on vous retrouve bien là
effectivement vous nous aviez manqué
pendant relativement peu de temps c'est
vrai mais je reviendrai effectivement
sur le fond du sujet et le rapporteur
général à juste titre fait objection à
sa collègue de l'assemblée nationale qui
a cru
astucieux de modifier les données
pour laisser croire qu'il serait
possible de faire moins d'efforts
d'économies
c'est quand même bien cela la motivation
de l'amendement qui a été voté à
l'assemblée nationale en répartissant
différemment et les éléments entre ce
qui est conjoncturelle et ce qui est
structurelle on oriente la politique
économique et ont défini on peut définir
de manière différente
les efforts à réaliser pour
contenir voire réduire nos finances
publiques
le rapporteur général
je le maintiens a eu raison de revenir
au texte initial du gouvernement pour
éviter que la france ne puisse être
prise en flagrant délit de de
manipulation de méthode et
d'interruption de la continuité de la
cohérence des séries mais
à l'occasion de ce débat
rappelons nous que les notions dont on
parle qui sont des notions économiques
complexes
lesquels nécessitent un éclairage
objectif par un haut conseil des
finances publiques
cette méthode ces notions sont forcément
inévitablement d'un maniement complexe à
la fois pour l'exécutif pour le
législatif est d'un abord ingrat pour
l'opinion publique
il faut en passer par là c'est vrai car
c'est la mesure commune qui s'impose à
l'ensemble des budgets au sein de
l'union européenne et plus
particulièrement de la zone euro
c'est l'un des outils de la convergence
et de la cohérence entre les pays qui
partagent une même monnaie
il n'en reste pas moins que pour faire
en prendre à nos concitoyens ce qui se
passe et à quel point il est nécessaire
de les faire participer à l'effort
d'assainissement des finances publiques
pip potentiel efforts structurels sont
d'un secours assez limité car notion il
faut en convenir monsieur le ministre je
vois votre sourire notion assez
difficile à acclimater dans le débat
public ce que je veux simplement dire
c'est que même si ces notions sont
indispensables et représente cet outil
cet instrument de mesure communs ce
thermomètre qu'il faut respecter en tant
que tel il serait quand même bon de
maintenir
une
appréciation une considération pour le
solde effectif pour une appréciation des
économies qui ne se mesure pas seulement
par rapport à une tendance ce que je ne
conteste pas monsieur le secrétaire
d'état au budget au niveau de la méthode
et vous l'avez dit très justement cette
méthode elle est appliquée depuis un
certain nombre d'années mais pour faire
comprendre il n'y a quand même qu'une
seule façon de faire il y avait tant de
crédit en 2013 il y en a tant en 2014 en
euros courants
c'est la seule chose qui puisse montrer
qu'il y a véritablement un effort que
l'on demande pardonnez moi de le dire
quelques sacrifices à tel ou tel
dispensateur de l'argent public est au
demeurant il est bien un domaine où vous
le faites mais sur les ministres c'est
le domaine des collectivités
territoriales ou là les dotations elle
diminue bien en euros courants et vous
utilisez la bonne méthode si j'ose dire
puisque vous commencez par articuler le
montant de la baisse donc ceci est au
moins pour le budget de l'état une vraie
économie alors que et j'en terminerai
par là et seul reproche que je faisais
tout à l'heure en discussion générale au
gouvernement sur les années à venir pour
ce qui est de la programmation de nos
finances publiques dans les années à
venir il est indispensable d'avoir une
prévision des mesures en recettes avec
le rendement en euro et des mesures en
dépenses avec leur appréciation en euros
et pas seulement des fractions de pointe
de pipe toute chose qui il faut en
convenir son d'un maniement assez
technique est assez complexe mais dans
l'immédiat je pense que le rapporteur
général a été vraiment dans le droit fil
des bonnes méthodes en nous proposant
cet amendement
merci monsieur le président je vais donc
mettre aux voix
cet amendement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté
je mets donc qu'on voit dans l'article
je mets donc on voit l'article liminaire
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il est adopté nous en
arrivons à l'article 1er avec un
amendement 142 monsieur de l'est vous
avez la parole oui monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues il s'agit effectivement d'un
amendement de suppression de cet article
1er c'est vrai que lorsque le président
de la république a annoncé le pacte de
responsabilité au début de l'année
il m'avait semblé en tout cas entendre
et je pense que beaucoup de
commentateurs avaient entendu que il
souhaitait d'abord et avant tout
essayé de restituer des marges aux
entreprises
puisqu'aujourd'hui les marges des
entreprises sont très basses et c'est ce
qui pénalise énormément l'investissement
et la création d'emplois et donc il
avait souhaité il me semble mettre
vraiment l'accent sur la politique ce
qu'on appelle la politique de l'offre et
j'étais très très surpris quand j'ai
entendu le premier ministre juste avant
les élections européennes annonce est un
geste en faveur des revenus modestes et
des personnes à revenus modestes
j'ai été effectivement très très surpris
d'entendre
cette annonce et on en voit la
traduction aujourd'hui dans ce plfr et
je dirais presque que c'est
la principale motivation presque de ce
plfr puisque le reste sont que des
ajustements et je m'attendais mois plus
tôt à disposition en faveur des
entreprises et les dispositions que l'on
voit en faveur des entreprises c'est la
pérennisation une année de plus d'une
contribution exceptionnelle sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés donc c'est vrai que
j'ai été très très surpris et on nous a
annoncé que cette disposition
qui me semblait aussi exceptionnel
allait finalement devenir pérenne
qu'elle avait cette année un financement
grâce aux amendes
qui sont versées par les riches
fraudeurs donc c'est moralement très
intéressant mais au-delà de cette année
si cette mesure est pérenne je n'en vois
pas
le financement durable sauf par
l'emprunt et moi je ne suis pas
favorable à un financement de cadeaux
fiscaux par l'emprunt donc je considère
d'abord que le financement n'est pas
pérenne donc ça m'embête ensuite que
c'est une mesure qui est destinée à
corriger un certain nombre d'effets des
excès fiscaux que vous avez vous même
provoquer avec notamment la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et valérie rabault
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale l'a
très bien montré dans son rapport qu' il
y a beaucoup de personnes qui se
retrouvent imposable du fait de vos
décisions et donc à travers ce cadeau
fiscal vous corriger cette l'effet de
ces décisions est le dernier point moi
je suis plutôt partisan que tout le
monde paye des impôts même si c'est des
montants très faible parce que des
produits très faible mais que tout le
monde participe au financement de la
peau et donc j'ai personnellement un
fils qui est en contrat d'alternance
l'an dernier il a il a gagné le smic il
a gagné quatorze mille euros sur l'année
j'avais calculé son apogée cette année
c'était 200 300 euros je vais être
content il va pas les payer mais
honnêtement je je je trouverai je
trouverais normal qui après une année à
voir p gagné quatorze mille euros qui
payent entre 300 et 400 200 et 300 euros
ça me semblait pas anormal voilà donc je
tenais à le dire et c'est pour ça que
j'ai aussi déposé cet amendement merci
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
président la vie est un petit peu
compliqué dans sa formulation puisque à
titre personnel je suis défavorable à
cet amendement
je suis défavorable parce que ce dont il
s'agit savoir la réduction
exceptionnelle d'impôt sur le revenu
proposée par le gouvernement va
bénéficier à près de 3,7 millions de
ménages dont 1 9 million deviendront non
imposés et elle correspond au total à
une restitution pouvoir d'achat de 1 16
milliard financés par les bons résultats
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale donc
c'est une mesure simple lisible et
d'effets immédiats
et de plus cette mesure n'exclut pas
bien sur une réforme de fond de l'impôt
sur revenu que le gouvernement a annoncé
pour 2015 donc il me semble tout à fait
de bon sens que de mettre en oeuvre
cette disposition c'est ce que j'ai
proposé à
la commission des finances en indiquant
que j'étais défavorable à cet amendement
mais la commission des finances a été
dans sa majorité d'un avis différent et
s'est prononcé majoritairement en faveur
de cet amendement voilà ce que je devais
vous dire au sujet de la proposition
faite par notre collègue dollars
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
ainsi monsieur le président du
gouvernement est évidemment défavorable
la suppression de cet article qui est
l'une des justifications de ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative comme nous
l'avons évoqué lors de la discussion
générale
de remarques
la première vous dit il n'y a pas dans
ce texte mesures favorables aux
entreprises hormis
le report à l'année prochaine de la fin
de
la surtaxe à l'impôt sur les sociétés
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à cette même
tribune qu' il fallait considérer la
globalité des deux textes pfr plfss par
la constitution ne nous oblige à avoir
deux textes différents s'agissant de
deux sujets différents
dans le second texte que dont vous
connaissez la teneur le gouvernement
proposera la suppression d'une première
part de la c3s pour un milliard d'euros
dont je me dois de préciser monsieur je
n'ai pas encore fait qu'elle sera mise
en place à la faveur d'un abattement
d'assiettes de 3 millions d'euros sur le
chiffre d'affaires des entreprises donc
elle va profiter mécaniquement aux
petites entreprises du moins à celle qui
est plus petit de celles qui paient la
c3s c'est à dire les deux tiers
deux cent mille entreprises sur les 300
milles qui paye aujourd'hui la c3s
deuxièmement il y aura une mesure à
hauteur de quatre milliards et demi
d'allègements de cotisations sociales
pour les entreprises sur les salariés
c'est la mesure dite zéro charges payées
à l'urssaf au niveau du smic donc façon
dégressive entre un smig et 1,6 fois le
smic donc les mesures lourdes puisque
j'ai évoqué un milliard d'un côté quatre
milliards et demi de l'aude sont dans le
plfss ma deuxième remarque peut
polémiquer pour savoir quels sont les
contribuables qui sont à en parlons
quelles sont les raisons qui ont conduit
à semble contribuables à entrer dans
l'impôt sur revenu voire même de
l'opportunité que certains soient
complètement exonérés
je crois que là on pourrait énumérer un
certain nombre de raisons qui sont liées
à la précédente majorité la demi part
des veuves le gel successifs du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu effectivement
d'autres mesures ont été prises après
l'alternance comme il est convenu de
dire et donc gouvernement souhaite
effectivement
revenir en arrière pour
éviter que trop de contribuables entre
dans la peau sur le revenu alors après
qui payent l'impôt l'impôt sur le revenu
la tva la cg c'est un débat extrêmement
intéressant mais pour toutes ces raisons
et même encore quelques autres
ont rajouté par exemple sur la recette
pérenne que je doute que l'ensemble des
dossiers traités par le stade hier le
soin cette année j'ai l'occasion tout à
l'heure d'évoquer le fait qu' on aura un
élargissement de l'assiette de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune qui à mon
avis produira une pas à la totalité du
coût de cette mesure sur l'occasion de
revoir soir de revoir tout ça en loi de
finances initiale du gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement de
suppression merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur de la peau explications de vote
ainsi le président
après les vacances et finalement les
français vont recevoir leur feuille
d'impôts
et en dehors des exonérations
effectivement prévu on dira à la marge
dans ce texte
l'augmentation est en moi de l'impôt sur
le revenu sera de l'ordre de 3,5 et 4
milliards d'euros en plus
alors 95% des 9 millions de salariés
dans le même temps qu'ils effectuent des
heures supplémentaires ils vont être
touchés par la défiscalisation
libérant environ 500 euros en moyenne
par an 7 millions de retraités au
minimum se retrouvant aussi imposable
donc avec une retraite de facto au but
et on ne parle pas de ceux qui subiront
la fiscalisation de la majoration des
pensions de retraite parce qu'ils ont
élevé trois enfants
et
l'abondement dans l'assiette de l'impôt
sur le revenu des complémentaires santé
en réalité le gouvernement ne veut pas
revivre ce qu'il a vécu à la rentrée il
ya un an et on le comprend donc un
centre de mesures ponctuelles ont été
prises et à notre sens si ça peut aller
dans le bon sens
ça ne touche vraiment pas les couches
moyennes de la société française en
réalité vos choix ne concerne que les
ménages qui touche au minimum que à un
smic donc trois sets mais on est là sur
36 millions de foyers fiscaux nous nous
estimons que la classe moyenne votre
approche est inexact de ce qu'elle est
réellement ce qui touche à 2 smic ou
plus de disposeront que d'un droit de
payer totalement leurs impôts et toutes
les charges qui ont avec
messieurs ministre des classes moyennes
sont dans ce pays en général des
stabilisateurs de la république et même
de la démocratie et vous avez pu
constater avec nous les dégâts que cela
peut qu'on a mené aux dernières
élections européennes et nous pensons
qu'il aurait été utile indispensable
d'étendre ce dispositif à une tranche
beaucoup plus large le 10 à 12 millions
de foyers fiscaux et que votre approche
donc des classes moyennes est inexact et
votre dispositif nettement insuffisant
alors pour toutes ces raisons monsieur
le président messieurs les ministres
nous soutiendrons et voteront ce cet
amendement de nos collègues de lui dit
merci monsieur doligé
président messieurs les ministres chers
collègues dont j'ai essayé de ne pas
faire trop de redites par rapport à mon
collègue bien sûr qu'il vient de
s'exprimer puisque je suis en total
accord avec lui-même d'abord je remercie
notre collègue de l'aed avoir déposé cet
amendement puisque l'on sait tous que
l'article 1 d'un texte est en général
celui qui donne le sens du texte et j'ai
le sentiment
il ya deux ou trois jours que sur le
découpage des régions c'était l'article
1 qui était le plus important et vous
avez vu le sort qui lui a été fait par
notre assemblée nous peut-être que nous
aurons le même sort pour cet article 1
je me demande aussi d'ailleurs si ce
texte est toujours nécessaire puisque
tout à l'heure j'ai vu un extrait de la
conférence sociale ou le président de la
république s'est exprimé et en faisant
un grand geste de la main il nous a dit
la crise est terminée donc à la limite
si si c'est vrai c'est peut-être plus la
peine de se donner beaucoup de mal à
essayer de trouver des solutions pour
relancer notre activité notre économie
puisqu'il ya plus de crise
l'article 1 propose donc une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat avec un objectif qui est
bien sûr louable et pertinents louable
puisqu'il met en évidence les
revirements des positions
changeantes et et permanente de la
majorité qui après avoir assommé
fiscalement les français pendant deux
ans fait machine arrière et décide de
lui redonner une partie de celle qu'il
avait prélevé pourtant on considère que
le moyen n'est pas pertinent pour les
raisons qui ont été dits par mon
collègue delattre puisque les classes
moyennes sont laissés totalement de côté
par exemple pour un couple qui gagne
entre 2400 et 3500 euros par mois donc
je parle d'un couple il sera pas
concerné par la baisse de la fiscalité
sur le rpp en outre ceux qui sortiraient
de l'impôt ne sont pas forcément
exactement tous ceux qui sont rentrés
donc on voit bien que ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes mais la vraie
justice fiscale serait bien sûr de
rétablir ce que vous avez supprimé afin
de remettre chacun dans le droit
antérieur je vous rappelle qu'à qu'à
l'automne prochain la hausse de la
fiscalité qui a été voté ces dernières
années va se faire durement ressentir et
notamment pour les classes moyennes qui
n'auront aucune mesure en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat
je vous rappelle que la fiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires touchera
encore plus durement 8 millions de
salariés concernés puisque en 2014 la
fiscalisation concernera toute l'année
2013 alors qu'en 2013 cela n'a concerné
qu'une partie de l'année 2012 donc cette
année nous aurons si j'ose dire un impôt
plein pot sur une année complète pour
les personnes qui bénéficient avant
de cet avantage sur les heures
supplémentaires dont bien évidemment
nous voterons contre l'article 1er et
nous voterons pour l'amendement de de
suppression vous dire également que le
coût pour les finances publiques de
votre réduction d'impôt c'est de 1,1
milliard et que l' avantage sur les
heures supplémentaires c'est est de 1
milliard donc il était facile de
rétablir les heures les heures
supplémentaires qui elle concernait huit
millions de salariés alors que là vous
allez concerner 3 7 millions de français
voilà les raisons pour lesquelles nous
pensons qu'il n'est pas bon de suivre la
proposition que vous avez fait est que
nous voterons bien sûr pour l'amendement
notre collègue de l'oeil si monsieur
gorce
chez le président je voulais remercier
mes collègues de l'est doligé parce que
c'est vrai que quand je vois parfois ce
que fait le gouvernement je me pose des
questions mais quand j'entends
l'opposition je me retrouve
parce que là pour le coup les choses
sont clairement dit vous qui avez voté
sans hésitation le bouclier fiscal et
qui à l'époque tu vous faisait pas
preuve d'une très grande émotion par
rapport à l'injustice que ça pouvait
représenter vous qui désigné pour vous
exprimer en votre nom monsieur dassault
qui nous propose rien moins que de
supprimer la progressivité de l'impôt
joseph cailloux devait sans doute se
retourner plus d'une fois dans sa tombe
on l'entend dont vous êtes maintenant
tout à fait cohérent en proposant
effectivement d'empêcher des français de
bénéficier d'une mesure fiscale qui
concernera les plus modestes donc merci
au moins de m'aider à retrouver un peu
mes esprits dans ces débats économiques
que je trouve déjà suffisamment
compliqué mais qu'il a autrement pour le
coup retrouve une très très grande
clarté
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 140 et je suis saisi à
monsieur présent marini pardonnez moi
faire un commentaire
d'ordre purement budgétaire dans
ce collectif budgétaire
parti que le premier créé sans doute de
façon durable sinon on ne comprendrait
pas la finalité du dispositif une
dépense supplémentaire
qui est de 1,16 milliard d'euros si je
ne me trompe
et la décision en la matière a été
annoncé et très vite prise enfin en
l'espace de quelques semaines
cette amélioration du barème qui vous
semblent tout à fait évidente
aujourd'hui messieurs les ministres et
qui est approuvée avec beaucoup de
conviction par notre collègue monsieur
gorce par exemple eh bien elle ne
faisait pas partie de l'analyse
qui a prévalu lors du projet de loi de
finances pour 2014 il n'y a pourtant que
quelques mois et on nous dit est que ce
pays fait des efforts en vue d'assurer
la convergence de ses finances publiques
et or
je m'interroge sur le financement de
cette mesure alors vous avez trouvé
opportunément une plus value d'un
milliard d'euros sur les recettes issues
des rapatriements de capitaux
plus value par rapport à l'estimation de
la loi de finances et vous dit de
manière extrêmement habile voilà ce sont
les aînés les les retours des personnes
qui avaient des capitaux à l'étranger
qui viennent nous permettre
opportunément
d'alléger la charge de ces ménages
modestes pour qui bien entendu
nous avons un intérêt
incontestable
et simplement en pur rigueur budgétaire
quand une dépense est permanente il est
préférable qu'il y est en face une
recette de caractère permanent or la
récurrence de cette recette issue des
rapatriements de capitaux
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel point elle
est permanente je sais comment collègue
gilles carez a posé quelques questions
dans le débat à l'assemblée nationale
nous allons nous allons d'ailleurs
monsieur le secrétaire d'état au budget
vous questionnez plus précisément
en ce en ce domaine mais s'il ya par
exemple des pénalités les pénalités
elles ne vont pas se reproduire
quel est dans le rapatriement
des capitaux et parmi les recettes
qu'ils engendrent la part qui est à
considérer comme récurrentes et la part
qui est si j'ose dire one shot et je
crois que cette démonstration n'a pas
encore été fait et en tout état de cause
il serait utile que vous nous éclairer
sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs d'abord heureux
d'être avec vous pour
appuyer aider dans cette discussion qui
est importante le secrétaire d'état
quelques commentaires
contrairement à ce que j'entends dire
ici ou là l'analyse du gouvernement sur
la situation macroéconomique sous les
besoins de notre économie n'est pas une
analyse en noir ou blanc c'est pas soit
l'offre
soit la demande soit les entreprises
soient les ménages nous pensons qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un problème considérable que
nous appellerons de compétitivité de
capacité pour nos entreprises à faire
face à si bien la demande en france le
produit par des français qui vont
parfois les acheter à l'extérieur aussi
de capacité à faire face à des
possibilités à l'extérieur de vente de
nos produits nous sommes dans une
concurrence internationale et nos
entreprises et ça ne date pas de deux
mois ou de deux ans et une dégradation
continue depuis plus de 10 ans sont
aujourd'hui peu armée pas suffisamment
armé d'où une politique
qui leur redonne des capacités ses
capacités pour en tête des capacités
d'investissement c'est aussi une forme
de demande des capacités d'innovation
des capacités de combat à l'exportation
des capacités aussi dans bausch lorsque
ses besoins là peuvent s'exprimer dans
l'entreprise mais nous n'avons jamais
dit que c'était le seul sujet et que
pour faire face à la situation
d'aujourd'hui il suffisait d'agir dans
ce seul domaine et nous avons toujours
dit qu'il y avait en particulier dans
les catégories les plus modestes des
français des questions dites de pouvoir
d'achat qui peuvent se traduire aussi en
terme de consommation du fait tout
particulièrement de l'augmentation
soyons justes par les uns comme par les
autres des impôts pesant sur les ménages
et tout particulièrement sur les plus
modestes de ses ménages je pourrais vous
citer christian haquin l'a déjà fait des
mesures qui continuent à avoir des
effets encore aujourd'hui qui ont été
décidées par la majorité de l'époque par
exemple cette affaire deux demi-parts
des veuves qui continuent à avoir des
effets aujourd'hui je pourrais vous
citer évidemment le gel du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu que vous aviez
institué et qui a eu des conséquences
récurrente pour les plus modestes des
ménages qui sont rentrés ainsi dans
l'impôt sur le revenu et donc nous
souhaitons par cette mesure faire en
sorte je ne dirais pas que tous ceux qui
se sont mis à payer l'impôt alors que
leurs revenus n'avaient pas augmenté
puis s'en sortir parce que nous sommes
jamais sûrs de pouvoir le faire ménage
par ménage mais que globalement il y est
un effet de retrait de l'impôt sur le
revenu d'une grande partie de ce que
vous comme nous avons pu faire part
telle et telle mesure rentré dans
l'impôt sur le revenu je dis ça parce
que je n'aime pas trop ces raisonnements
qui sont tout ou rien dans une économie
comme la nôtre dans une situation
complexe comme la nôtre faut pas être
dans le tout rien faut essayer de faire
des choses sont toujours discutable
toujours discuter évidemment à la fois
du point de vue économique et du point
de vue politique mais qui soient les
plus équilibrés possibles et les plus
nous le pensons adapté à la situation
possible deuxième partie de ma réponse à
votre question sur le président
parfaitement légitime d'abord
permettez-moi de vous reprendre sur un
terme vous dites vous créez une dépense
supplémentaire
nous diminuons en impôts
ah voilà ça y va pour le solde oui mais
voilà c'était étrange mélange qui se
fait on a même appelé ça à un moment
donné de la dépense fiscale parce que
comme on pouvait plus faire c'était
beaucoup par vous de dépenses
budgétaires on s'est mis à faire plein
dépenses fiscales comme vous le disiez
vous même les faits elle même le sol
s'est dégradée
donc aujourd'hui nous essayons d'être
rigoureux nous essayons d'être rigoureux
et de raisonner en terme de pression
fiscale de fiscalité là nous baissons la
fiscalité sur les plus modestes des
français et nous raisonnons par ailleurs
en termes de dépenses de dépenses
budgétaires que nous cherchons à
maîtriser et même parfois éliminé je
pense que vous allez avoir l'occasion
d'en parler dans quelques heures à
propos des articles qui vont vous seront
proposés pour supprimer un certain
nombre de dépenses budgétaires mais sur
la question de l'autre impôts puisque
c'est un impôt qui viendrait compenser
la baisse d'impôt nous sommes dans le
cadre des prélèvements obligatoires une
baisse des prélèvements obligatoires sur
les plus modestes et une hausse du
prélèvement obligatoire sur qui sur que
ceux sur qui ne paient aucun prélèvement
obligatoire parce que leurs acquis à
l'étranger n'était pas à déclaré
deuxième petite rectification de
vocabulaire mais pour que chacun se
comprenne il ne s'agit pas de gagner de
l'argent sur le rapatriement des
capitaux le contribuable français qui
placent de l'argent au hasard en suisse
a parfaitement le droit de placer de
l'argent en suisse s'ils considèrent que
le banquier suisse va mieux gérer son à
voile a parfaitement le droit de le
faire ce qui n'a pas droit de faire
c'est de le cacher et de ne rien
déclarer au fisc français qu'il s'agisse
des revenus de ces capitaux ou qu'il
s'agisse de la valeur de ces capitaux au
titre en particulier de l'île je termine
nous avions prévu cette année d'abord
300 millions puis au cours de la
discussion budgétaire à la fin des
dernières 800 millions de venus qui sont
les revenus des impôts et bien entendu
des pénalités qui pèsent sur les avoirs
qu'ils sont désormais déclarés cela va
beaucoup plus vite que nous l'avions
prévu nous avons dépassé le milliard
d'impôts et de pénalités nous sommes
presque à 1 milliard 200 millions
aujourd'hui là au moment où je vous
parle donc il n'y a aucune difficulté à
atteindre le milliard 800 millions qui
nous permettra de compenser à l'euro
près et même au delà pour cette année
pour cette année j'ai compris votre
question et je vais y répondre pour
cette année et donc nous équilibreront
la mesure exceptionnelle dans son
principe pas exceptionnelle dans sa
durée d'où la pertinence de votre
question mais exceptionnelle dans son
principe de cette année par une recette
qui n'est pas totalement exceptionnel
mais qui n'est pas reconduite tible
d'année en année parce qu'une fois que
les choses sont déclarés il n'ya plus
par exemple de pénalité sur les impôts à
payer je pense que l'année prochaine
nous n'aurons pas tout à fait
complètement épuisé les régularisations
même si les choses vont vite peut-être
que certains des contribuables auront
comment dire est ce plus de lenteur à
comprendre où est leur intérêt même si
aujourd'hui un bon nombre d ceux qui
gèrent leur actif les pousse à déclarer
à rendre transparentes leurs revenus
donc l'année prochaine je pense qu'il
continuera à y avoir des revenus
importants de ce point de vue mais
viendra le jour où tout ayant été
déclarée reviendront quoi les impôts
normaux payer sur ses hommes juste à
titre d'information pour le sénat quels
sont aujourd'hui les sommes qui sont
sortis de l'ombre à l'occasion de ces
déclarations la selle qui nous ont
permis de penser que
1 milliard 100 milliards deux cents
aujourd'hui ont été touchés c'est plus
de 25 milliards sur ce rythme là on peut
penser qu'on va dépasser les 50
milliards peut-être 60 milliards
d'avoirs non déclarés qui seront
déclarées 60 milliards d'avoirs qui
produise quoi des revenus qui vont être
imposés imposé de manière durable et
reconductible fin simple 60 milliards
qui pour la plupart du temps me semble
qu'il devrait appartenir à des gens qui
payent par ailleurs l'impôt sur la
fortune c'est une base nouvelle qui est
sortie de long qui va servir au calcul
de l'impôt sur la fortune pour les
années de manière récurrente pas au même
niveau j'en convient tout à fait mais à
des niveaux tout à fait important donc
vous voyez bien le faire sortir de
l'ombre ça rapporte de l'argent
immédiatement mais ça on rapporte aussi
dans la durée
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur de
la haye
oui monsieur le président messieurs mise
pour une explication de vote mais
je voudrais dire que cette disposition
moi elle me surprend me surprend d'abord
parce que le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault je l'aï dit tout à l'heure ici
en octobre 2012 nous avait dit que les
augmentations d'impôts ne toucherait pas
neuf français sur dix
il est parti mais avant de partir il
nous a dit qu'il allait faire une remise
à plat totale du système fiscal français
ce à quoi nous avions dit chiche et que
nous avions beaucoup d'espoir
effectivement sur cette remise à plat
que nous ne voyons pas venir au lieu
d'une remise à plat on voit cette
première disposition qui n'étaient pas
intégrées jeu j'étais là pour écouter le
discours qu'ils étaient lus par laurent
fabius pour le premier ministre son
discours de politique générale il m'a
pas semblé entendre dans ce discours à
aucun moment une disposition de ce type
et premiers textes financiers que nous
avons à étudier ici au sénat la première
mesure qui tombe c'est ce cadeau fiscal
voilà moi je suis pour une remise à plat
totale du système fiscal français y
compris pour les revenus modestes que
l'on fasse est revenu cette remise à
plat tranquillement et avec la
participation de tous mais je ne suis
pas pour des mesures ponctuelles qui ont
été visiblement décidé dans l'urgence et
dont le financement je reviens là dessus
d'eux n'est pas pérenne et donc ça sera
une mesure qui sera financée par la
dette donc je n'y suis pas favorable
c'est pour ça que je maintiens mon
amendement
merci je vais donc le métro mais je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe ump sur l'amendement
numéro 140 nous allons donc procéder aux
réparations de scrutin public
c'est toi qu'est ce que tu as tort
tout est ouvert
le scrutin est clos et nous allons
procéder à son dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 115 sur
l'amendement numéro 140 nombre de
votants 342 noms de suffrages exprimés
341 pour l'adoption 164 contre 177 le
sénat n'a pas adopté l'amendement 140 et
nous en arrivons à deux ans maintenant
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
tout d'abord le 55
monsieur bloqué ce président ce ministre
chers collègues l'impôt sur le revenu
est de longue date l'élément principal
du débat fiscal dans notre pays alors
même qu'il ne constitue qu'un élément
insuffisamment pertinent de notre
système fiscal nous constatons
d'ailleurs que le présent projet de loi
de finances comporte une mesure celle de
l'article 1er qui fait de cet impôt le
témoin affiché de la démarche de
réduction des impôts promise par le
gouvernement que pèseront ceci dit les
350 euros de ristourne aux ménages d'ici
trois ans quand nous aurons vu par
ailleurs 38 milliards d'euros de
cotisations sociales et d'impôts rendu
aux seules entreprises
cela dit un autre amendement propose
renforcer notre barème progressif
plusieurs fois remodelé ces dernières
années selon une tendance structurelle à
la réduction de la contribution des plus
hauts revenus et à l'accroissement
relative de la contribution des bas et
moyens revenus il importe de prendre une
nouvelle orientation d ce projet doit
sinon certificative c'est à dire assurer
un bon rendement de l'impôt dans la
justice et l'équité de fait il nous
semble que deux mesures essentielles
sont nécessaires et de ce site de
manière quasi impérieuse d'une part il
faut revenir sur le gel du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu en ajustant les
seuils des différentes tranches de
l'impôt une évolution au moins
équivalente ou peu s'en faut au niveau
de l' indice des prix à la consommation
qui a servi de base de calcul
macroéconomiques pour les dernières lois
de finances et d'autre part il convient
de modifier le seuil d'application de la
tranche à 45% et nous proposons de créer
une nouvelle tranche à 50% 45 % du
produit le départ en réalité à partir
d'un revenu déclaré par par deux cent
cinquante mille euros tout en restant
très éloigné d'une logique confiscatoire
qu'on a pu entendre à un moment où
l'impôt sur le revenu ainsi modifié
présenterait un caractère plus
progressif et donc plus juste assurant à
l'état en même temps un rendement
suffisant pour constituer enfin une
recette essentiel de son budget de fait
la raison d'être principale et ses
amendements et le procurer à l'état un
certain rendement fiscal ce qui
permettrait à notre système de
prélèvements d'être mieux équilibrée et
plus juste tout en dégageant les
ressources nécessaires à une politique
publique fondée sur la réparation de les
inégalités sociales un impôt sur le
revenu plus justement prélevés pour une
allocation judicieuse de l'argent public
tel est l'objet de cet amendement que
nous vous invitons mes chocolats gars
adopter mercy mercy amendement 81,18
rectifié qu'il défend monsieur colin oui
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues comme
nous l'avons annoncé dans la discussion
générale et même si nous aurions préféré
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire une
refonte globale de notre système fiscal
pour le rendre plus lisible plus juste
nous soutenons l'article premier de ce
collectif budgétaire qui vise à
préserver les ménages modestes dont les
revenus n'ont pas augmenté des effets
d'une entrée dans le barème de l'impôt
sur le revenu
3.7 millions de foyers fiscaux devraient
être concernés par cette mesure
exceptionnelle 1,1 million deviendront
ou resteront en impose et 1,3 million
déjà nous l'imposé verront la
restitution augmenter et 5000 verront
leur impôt diminuer la réduction de
l'impôt sur le revenu prévues par cet
article est en partie familialiser c'est
à dire est qu'il est tenu compte de la
composition du foyer fiscal pour son
attribution ainsi les limites de revenus
pour bénéficier de cet allégement seront
majorés de 3556 euros par demi part
supplémentaire
afin de prendre en compte le nombre de
personnes à charge
le présent amendement propose d'élargir
la mesure à 90 ans
la majoration du seuil de revenus par
2000 par qui permettent aux familles de
bénéficier de réductions d'impôt
plafonnée à 700 euros pour un couple
soumis à imposition commune
nous proposons donc les limites de
revenus soit majorée de 4000 euros par
demi part afin de permettre un nombre
plus élevé de foyers de bénéficier de
cette mesure de justice fiscale vont
dans le sens de cet amendement que je
vous propose bien sûr d'adopter mercy
quel est l'avis de la commission sur ces
deux amendements monsieur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur le président la ville la
commission sera à peu près le même pour
les deux amendements le premier défendu
par nos collègues hockey à l'instant
visa réindexés le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'inflation des années
2000 11 12 et 13 ainsi qu'à créer une
tranche supérieure à 50% et en fait
contrairement à ce qui a été argumenté
puisque notre collègue nous disait qu'il
y avait des recettes supplémentaires
attendre nos propres estimations
conduisent à penser que ce serait
probablement coûteux voire assez coûteux
même puisque avec
la réindexation pour trois années
consécutives
on arrive en définitive un dispositif
qui n'apportent pas de recette mais qui
entraîne un coût important
et de plus
nous savons qu'il ya eu des arbitrages
de la part du gouvernement pour
restituer du pouvoir d'achat ceci vient
d'être évoquée à l'instant dans la
discussion nous avons eu ce article un
gouvernement a choisi de mettre en place
un dispositif pour donc les gens qui
rentraient dans l'impôt sur le revenu on
l'a évoqué 350 euros pour un célibataire
c'est 200 euros pour un couple donc il
ya déjà une restitution pouvoir d'achat
important plus d'un milliard bref tout
ceci me conduit à donner un avis
défavorable pour un événement qui serait
probablement coûteux et qui ne tient pas
compte de ces arbitrages qui ont été
faits déjà pour allonger alléger l'impôt
des ménages modestes pour le second
amendement
qui vient d'être défendu par nos
collègues du rdse
j'aurais tendance à demander le retrait
de cet amendement raison d'un coût
budgétaire
important là aussi d'autant que d'autres
mesures sont prises par ailleurs pour
alléger l'impôt sur les ménages modestes
et
notamment en ce qui concerne l'article
1er mais aussi en ce qui concerne les
mesures qui ont été prises dans le plfss
et pour ces raisons je souhaite donc le
retrait de ce deuxième amendement sinon
la vie sera défavorable
s'il y avait du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
du gouvernement rejoint l'avis du
rapporteur général concernant
l'amendement
défendu par monsieur bloquer
notre analyse est que le coût de cette
mesure serait de 2,7 milliards d'euros
parce que il faisait 2 effet en effet
dépenses en survalorisant les tranches
du bas du barème et puis
là j'aurai la dernière tranche mais je
comprendrais qu'à un coup pareil il est
évidemment impossible compte tenu du
contexte budgétaire qui donnait une
suite favorable
indépendamment d'autres arguments quotas
l'argument défendu par monsieur mézard
d'abord je voudrais lui dire que le
dispositif prend en compte la situation
familiale puisque il major le seuil de
revenu fiscal de référence qui ouvre
droit à la réduction d'impôt
d'un montant qui est de mémoire de 3500
36 euros proposés 4000 euros
pourquoi d'abord ça un coup ça a été dit
par votre rapporteur général qui dépasse
la centaine de millions d'euros selon
nos calculs et
deuxièmement ce coût n'a pas été passée
de ce montant n'a pas été fixée par asia
a par hasard par dont nous sommes calés
sur la méthode de calcul
qui est prise en compte dans la
majoration par enfant
qui intervient dans le calcul de la
prime pour l'emploi en prenant 25 % tu
delà du montant delà du fait du seuil
fixé pour une personne seule donc moi je
propose plutôt le retrait de cet
amendement a des fois je me montrerai
défavorable
merci explications de votre masque d'or
merci monsieur le président à peine
l'unité finance avait-il ouvert au débat
qu'il est malheureusement déjà reparti
vais lui répondre sans m'adresser
directement à lui mais monsieur eckert
et là dans le prolongement de la
discussion que nous avons eue je
n'assisterai pas au delà puisque
manifestement le gouvernement n'a pas
envie qu'on discute de ces questions je
m'en tiendrais donc à cette observation
et puis ensuite on pourra prendre
poursuivre dans l'examen du texte lui
même mais j'entends monsieur sapin nous
dira tout à l'heure mais au fond d'un
problème de compétitivité qui date au
moins dix ans et c'est vrai que nos
difficultés économiques date ou moins
dix ans si on regarde l'évolution notre
industrie nous emplois industriels le
rapport de monsieur gallois a montré que
nous avions perdu sur 20 ans plus de
deux millions d'emplois industriels près
d'un tiers la valeur ajoutée de
l'industrie sur les dix dernières années
et on peut en déduire différentes
conséquences on peut en déduire la
nécessité de jouer la carte de la
compétitivité par la baisse des
cotisations sociales après tout c'est
une hypothèse mais cette hypothèse elle
vient parce que l'on a renoncé à jouer
la carte du soutien à l'activité
économique et la relance européenne ans
je voudrais souligner quand même la
faiblesse de la démarche dans lequel
nous sommes engagés je comprends que le
gouvernement veuille s'y
engager puisqu'il n'a pas trouvé d'autre
option il n'a pas été capable ou n'a pas
la volonté de dégager une autre voie
mais la plupart de ceux qui examine la
situation sur les dix dernières années
nous explique que nos difficultés
industrielles sont moins liées à un
problème de compétitivité qu'on fait que
l'essentiel de l'activité industrielle
dans une zone monétaire unique a
tendance à se concentrer là où est déjà
la puissance industrielle autrement dit
la force industriel attire la force
industrielle sauf si vous avez une
politique sectorielle et des pics
régionales qui seront menées à l'échelle
de la zone c'est justement ce que nous
n'avons pas c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que la seule option
véritablement raisonnable dans lequel
nous pourrions nous engager traite une
option qui consisterait à travailler sur
une consolidation de la zone euro c'est
la vraie réponse aux problèmes auxquels
nous sommes confrontés à la fois parce
qu'elle traduit la nature de notre
engagement dans cette zone mais parce
qu'elle traduit aussi la volonté qui est
la nôtre de faire de cette zone un outil
de solidarité pas simplement un outil de
compétition ou dans laquelle la loi la
plus fore finirait par s'imposer il faut
définir une convergence de nos
politiques économiques il faut mettre en
place un outil politique de gestion
autour de ces convergences et nos
politiques budgétaires il faut donner
une priorité à la relance par
l'investissement bref ce sont des choix
politiques et quand j'entends que nous
n'aurions pas d'autre politique que
celle là je comprends tout nous n'ayons
pas d'autre si nous renonçons à nous
battre sur les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et sur les engagements que nous
avons pris mais à partir du moment où
nous faisons partie d'une entité qui
s'appelle l'union européenne qui s'est
construite autour d'un principe de
solidarité la logique c'est que le
gouvernement français plutôt que
d'expliquer aux ménages moyens de le
faire à l'instant sur le quotient
familial qui ne peut pas faire d'effort
supplémentaire ce que je peux comprendre
leur explique surtout aussi qui est en
train de se battre pour que l'europe
devienne à nouveau un niveau de
prospérité de croissance et pas un îlot
dans lequel la seule logique est celle
de la rigueur et de l'austérité au
détriment de nos emplois industriels
pour ce qui concerne les nations comme
les nôtres celles qui n'avaient pas un
avantage majeur dans ces domaines je
suis vraiment extrêmement désolé qu'on
ne puisse pas avoir ce débat ce que le
gouvernement ne s'explique pas sur ses
orientations parce que ce qui s'est
passé l'autre jeu à bruxelles mériterait
au moins qu'on sache pourquoi
cette option n'a pas été défendu
pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous explique que
c'est l'allemagne qui décident moi j'ai
un très grand respect pour l'allemagne
elle a fait des réformes qui sont tout à
fait conséquente qui expliquent une
partie de ces situations mais elle ne
constitue pas un modèle ni pour
l'économie pour la politique français
c'est à nous de définir ce que sont nos
intérêts comment nous voulons les
défendre et qui plus est ils vont dans
le sens d'une coopération européenne
renforcée on ne peut pas faire l'euro
c'est à dire la solidarité une seule
monnaie si on ne fait pas la solidarité
dans les politiques régionales
sectorielle et industriels sino ce que
l'on est en train de préparer c'est ce
qu'on a vu aux dernières élections
européennes
c'est le retour et le repli national
c'est à dire que ceux qui expliqueront
puisque on n'ira pas jusqu'au bout de la
logique dans la zone euro que la seule
solution par rapport à cela c'est le
repli national finalement ont tous les
arguments
ceux qui défendent l'idée de
l'intégration européenne un tiers de la
zone euro ont renoncé à construire cette
entité comme il le devrait c'est un
moment de responsabilité extrêmement
forts auxquels nous sommes confrontés et
sa de passe et de loin les enjeux de
savoir s'il ya une discipline de vote
qui appartient aux thèmes tel groupe c
les intérêts du pays qui sont en jeu les
engagements que nous avions pris depuis
un sombre d'année et si les résultats
des leurs échéances ne suffisent pas à
éclairer la majorité le gouvernement sur
ce qu'il convient de faire
mais je sais j'en connais d'autres qui
ne veulent pas entendre car nicole bricq
et c'est pas faute de me répéter mais je
ne vais pas le faire assure toi toute la
soirée j'essaye simplement de poser les
termes d'un débat sur lequel nous
devrions pouvoir avancer si on considère
que le rôle de la représentation
nationale est simplement effectivement
se prononcer par oui ou par non sur les
allemands budgétaire consistant à
modifier à la marge ou de manière
importante telle ou telle disposition
pourquoi pas moi je considère que dans
la situation où nous sommes nous
mériterions à vrai débat économique que
nous n'avons pas eu 10 dans cet
hémicycle ni à l'assemblée nationale il
faut pas s'étonner alors que les débats
partent ensuite dans tous les sens moi
je ne suis pas partisan de la position
qui consiste à faire de la guérilla
parlementaire apparemment non je crois
que la moindre des choses c'est que les
choses soient dites ici parce que les
français qui nous ont élus c'est ici
qu'ils nous regardent
merci je vais donc mettre voit ces deux
amendements commençant par le 55 quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 81,18
rectifier les maintenu monsieur colin il
est retiré il est retiré je vais mettre
aux voix l'article 1er quels sont ceux
qui souhaitent adopter l'article premier
avis contraire il est adopté après
l'article 1er un amendement 192 monsieur
delattre
monsieur
ce président monsieur lui s'il s'agit de
revenir sur la mauvaise décision de la
finance initiative qui avait diminué le
quotient familial
de 2000 euros à 1500 euros pour la
première partie nous considérons
toujours aujourd'hui que
c'est pas vraiment une mesure sociale le
quotient familial en réalité c'est un
mécanisme de solidarité à l'égard des
familles tout simplement entre ceux qui
ont des enfants et qui de par ce fait
même sa limite leur niveau de vie par
rapport à ceux des voiliers qui ne
dispose ne sont les mêmes revenus la
même capacité financière mais forcément
supporte des charges élevées les enfants
nous considérons même que ce sont des
investissements d'avenir
alors le
le coup naturellement est toujours élevé
on nous dit un milliard
sur rapporteur général ne nous parle
aussi de soutenir la croissance elle m'a
écouté à travers je pense une décision
de celle-ci forcément les familles qui
ont des enfants ont besoin d'investir
dans les écoles etc je trouve que nous
trouvons le groupe ump qu'il s'agit là
d'une mesure qui était
fort détestable et qui se révèle
économiquement elle aussi tout à fait
défavorable à ce que tout le monde n'a
l'air de
considérer comme étant la nécessité
absolue pour commencer à réduire au
moins notre chômage alors le débat sur
la compétitivité car on lancer notre
collègue
sénateur monsieur gorce
alors les rapports on les connaît très
bien le rapport gallois il y avait
trente mesures 30 mesures il est rapide
est parti on sait pas trouver les
failles du parti dans un compost
monsieur gallois et nous a laissé une
mesure sont les 30 qu'il avait préconisé
le cic dont tout le monde dit que ça
fait 20 milliards et dont nous attendons
monsieur rapporteur général de connaître
effectivement quels sont les vrais
chiffres parce qu'en réalité nous sommes
très bien notamment à ce que ce qui a
été dépensé par l'abbaye pays l'an
dernier que on sera loin d'attendre ces
chiffres et puisque notre collègue
naturellement nous a un peu interpellé
en disant que grâce à l'opposition et
retrouver ses marques au parti
socialiste je souhaiterais simplement
qu'il puisse regarder tout simplement le
rapport de la cour des comptes il ya un
graphique dans le rapport accorde et
compterait un camp très intéressant qui
concerne l'évolution des dépenses
publiques entre la france et l'allemagne
depuis 2001 2000 à 1 2000 vous savez
qu'il ya quand même une date pour
l'économie française importante c'est
quand même le passage aux 35 heures
alors on peut toujours discuter c'est
peut-être pas le seul facteur nous en
sommes d'accord mais c'est quand même à
des facteurs importants alors monsieur
lorsqu'en 2001 les cas entre nos deux
pays par rapport au pib était de quatre
poissons dépenses publiques d'ailleurs
que nous dépensions quatre points de
plus de pim aujourd'hui nous sommes à
douze points d'écart alors si nous
faisons un parallèle elle parallèle est
fait mon rapport des cours des comptes
avec la croissance de l'allemagne à un
taux de croissance bien supérieure un
seul de ce commerce extérieur bien
meilleurs que nous alors si
l'augmentation des dépenses publiques
a un effet sur la croissance on peut
quand même se demander raisonnablement
dans quel sens alors voilà mon cher
collègue qu'elle était l'objet d'une
amende mots que nous présentons au nom
du groupe ump qui vise à rétablir un
chiffre descend du quotient familial
pour aider les familles à élever leurs
enfants
i quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur rapporteur général
c'est un avis défavorable sur le
président j'ai été surpris d'entendre
notre collègue delattre tout d'un coup
se faire le défenseur d'une relance par
la consommation c'est en contradiction
totale et tout ce qui n'a pu lui dire
jusque là mais c'est l'argument qu'il a
développée en tout cas c'est un milliard
de moins pour les comptes de l'état
évidemment on ne peut pas être souverain
s'il y avait du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
mes os arguments du rapporteur général
le gouvernement voudra ajouté quelques
autres réflexions la diminution du
plafond du quotient familial
premièrement c'est pas la suppression du
quotient familial
contrairement aux siens souvent dit la
suppression du plafond du vin la
diminution du plafond du quotient
familial a été
mise en place pour assurer
l' équilibre de la branche famille et
pour respecter une idée qui je crois a
fait consensus en discuter qui est
l'universalité des allocations
familiales c'est à dire ne pas les faire
dépendre du revenu ce qui encore une
fois pour être soumis au débat mais je
crois que la consultation engagée à
l'époque avait ressorti plus tôt ce
consensus de même qu'elle avait exclu un
assujettissement à l'impôt des
allocations familiales qui était
également une option mis sur la table et
donc le choix retenu par le gouvernement
était celui d'une diminution quant aux
autres arguments techniques va pas
technique mais financiers en termes
équilibre je rejoins le rapporteur
général et suggère que
le scénar pouces cet amendement vie
défavorable
merci monsieur de lattes pour
explication de vote
aujourd'hui en reportant général qu'
on ne peut pas dire stricto sensu que
nous n'avons pas un problème de
croissance dans ce pays et on ne peut
pas dire que le problème de la
consommation du ménage n'est pas un
facteur qui contribue à une meilleure
croissance comme les investissements des
entreprises ce sont les deux principaux
moteurs alors nous pensons que c'est
mieux cibler que à 100 nombre de vos
mesures parce que les familles elles ont
des besoins tout simplement donc elles
vont pas thésauriser elles vont dépenser
et je pense que ça doit être valable à
brest comme dans toute la france
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement 192 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable et de la commission et du
gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
avis contraire
il n'est pas adoptée après l'article 1er
un amendement sans a rectifié qu'il
présente monsieur colin
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
lignée du précédent cet amendement vise
à renforcer les mesures en faveur des
ménages modestes plusieurs mesures
importantes ont déjà été adoptées dans
les textes budgétaires précédents ainsi
nous avons monté dans le projet de votre
finances pour
14 la fin du gel du barème de l'impôt
sur le revenu et la revalorisation des
seuils du revenu fiscal de référence qui
détermine comme chacun le sien grand
nombre d'abattements et d'exonérations
la décote qui permet de réduire les
effets de seuils liés à l'entrée dans le
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu pour les
ménages modestes a été revalorisé de 9%
en 2013 puis cinq minutes pour cent en
2014 passant de
480 à 508 euros ces mesures sont tout à
fait essentielle et témoigne de la
priorité monsieur le ministre accordée
par le gouvernement et la majorité ont
plus défavorisés et avec cet amendement
nous proposons d'accentuer je suis cet
effort en augmentant à nouveau la décote
de l'impôt sur le revenu qui passerait
de 508 à 514 euros voilà le sens de cet
amendement 109 rectifier que propose
adopter mercy quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci je président la commission va
demander un autre collègue ci peut
procéder au retrait de son amendement
pourquoi parce que nous avons
pris note que le gouvernement a décidé
de procéder successivement à de
revalorisation exceptionnelle de la
décote une réalisation de 9% en 2013
puis de 5 8% en 2014 c'est à dire bien
au delà de l'inflation et cette dernière
revalorisation d'ailleurs représente une
rétrocession de pouvoir d'achat de 193
millions d'euros pour 2014 et compte
tenu de ces de revalorisation ainsi que
d autres mesures prises en faveur des
ménages modestes jeu par les énumérer le
dégel du barème la réalisation des
seuils la réduction exceptionnelle
prévue par le plfr la baisse des charges
sociales je vous suggère le retrait pour
un amendement qui aurait un coût
important pour les finances publiques
sinon je ne pourrai être défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
demande
rejoindre encore une fois totalement
l'avis du rapporteur général il a
énuméré les mesures qui ont été prises
par le parlement d' vous avez vous même
dans la présentation de votre amendement
dit que la décote avait déjà été
fortement révolue et dans les deux
dernières lois de finances
conquis ont été adoptées par le
gouvernement et donc la mesure que vous
avez adopté à l'article 1er suffit à
elle même et le coût supplémentaire de
cette nouvelle sur réévaluation de la
décote ne serait pas admissible
avocats libres et par la réduction
d'impôt
et
compléter ainsi ce qui avait déjà été
fait un mot de finances initiale il n'y
a pas lieu d'adopter cet amendement s'il
n'était pas retiré gouvernement n'y
serait pas favorable
si l'amendement est retirée monsieur
colin et il est retiré
après l'article 1er l'amendement sans
rectifier et sans rectifié bis monsieur
colin
oui monsieur résident
ses ministres mes chers collègues vous
n'avez pas aimé mais deux amendements
monsieur le ministre vous allez adorer
celui ci
car il s'agit cette fois d'un amendement
qui propose de réaliser des économies
mes chers collègues à limitant le
bénéfice d'une niche fiscale dans un
souci de justice mais aussi des kits et
je tiens à préciser que l'on 30
assemblée a déjà adopté un amendement
identique au cours de la discussion du
projet de loi de finances pour 2014 il
s'agit ici de l'abattement prévu à
l'article 89 du code général des impôts
et qui permet aux journalistes et à
d'autres professionnels comme les
critiques musicaux où les photographes
d'affranchir les rémunérations d'impôts
jusqu'à 7650 euros avec cet amendement
nous proposons de réserver le bénéfice
s'est cru exonérations aux seuls
journalistes et aux autres
professionnels concernés dont la
rémunération n'excède pas 60 2340 euros
bruts annuels soit 4000 euros net par
mois
cela nous semble remplir un double
objectif de justice fiscale et
d'économie pour contribuer au
redressement de nos finances publiques
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à
confirmer le vote intervenu cet automne
en adoptant le présente amendements je
vous remercie de le voter dans un grand
enthousiasme
merci invite la commission fut
rapporteur général
eh bien monsieur le président mes chers
collègues l'amendement comme on vient de
le dire
combien le dis banco leur propose de
réserver le bénéfice
de l'exonération d'hier en faveur des
journalistes aux seuls journalistes dans
le revenu est inférieur à 4000 euros net
par mois
et c'est vrai comme vous l'avez rappelé
chers collègues un amendement identique
avait été adopté par le sénat à
l'occasion de l'examen du plf 2014 et
j'avais à l'époque indiqué que je
comprenais tout à fait là la
préoccupation légitime qui anime les
auteurs d'amendements et ses raisons
pour laquelle j'avais émis un avis de
sagesse l'an passé mais est il faut
rappeler qu'une telle disposition
aboutirait à réserver la déductibilité
des frais professionnels à certaines
catégories journalistes ce qui semble
sans doute difficilement justifiable
endroit et de plus il faut noter que
cette disposition aboutirait à des
effets de seuil assez fort
et surtout ne faut pas oublier que cette
dépense fiscale constitue une forme d'
aides à la presse dont chacun connaît
les difficultés actuelles pour ces trois
raisons je
préconise donc le retrait de cet
amendement et c'est la vie qui a été ce
matin partagée par la commission des
finances donc je vous suggère de retirer
dans votre rendement
si l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui le gouvernement
estime que cet amendement
serait contraire à la notion de
d'égalité devant les charges publiques
puisqu'il propose de réserver cette
modalité de prise en charge des frais
professionnels à une partie seulement
des journalistes façon c'est uniquement
pour les journalistes ça c'est déjà un
fait
et vous proposer de la cordée que sous
condition de ressources des journalistes
ce qui à notre sens introduirait une
rupture d'égalité devant les charges
publiques et
serait une fragilité pardon constituent
fonctionnel qui nous paraît évidente je
suggère plutôt de retirer cet amendement
à défaut je souhaiterais que le sénat le
repousse
merci l'amendement est maintenue
monsieur colin
merci monsieur gâteau là pour
l'explication de vote
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues les
écologistes par nature ne sont pas
favorables ou privilèges ou niches
fiscales mais dans le cas présent je
crois qu'il est absolument important de
rappeler la situation de la presse dans
ce pays nous comptons officiellement à
peu près trente sept mille personnes qui
disposent d'une carte de presse de plus
en plus de gens à l'intérieur de cet
univers qui sont au chômage en situation
précaire aujourd'hui et depuis en gros
le milieu des années 2000 le nombre de
journalistes en france régresse alors
que le nombre de supports d'information
notamment via internet via les nouveaux
médias augmente bref la richesse de
l'information la qualité de
l'information est en train de
disparaître parce que nous n'avons plus
de journalistes professionnels
nous avons dans les sites internet
d'information ce qu'on appelle des
gestionnaires de contenu qui n'ont pas
de formation qui font ce qu'on appelle
du desk de la compilation d'informations
déjà publiés et je crois que dans
l'univers des aides à la presse que l'on
peut contester dans ces chiffres et dans
certains de ses choix c'est une des
rares z qui est une aide justement au
volume et à la qualité journalistique
parce qu'elle permet aux entreprises
effectivement c'est un avantage fiscal
de rémunérer en tous les cas
indirectement grâce à cet abattement de
proposer des salaires dans des
situations économiques difficiles des
entreprises de presse notamment celles
qui embauchent le plus la presse
quotidienne nationale ou régionale
d'avoir des gens de qualité alors cette
niche fiscale elle a évalué par la cour
des comptes à 60 millions d'euros alors
ce que proposent l'amendement de
monsieur mézard et colin c'est
effectivement de toucher les personnes
qui gagnent plus de 4000 euros de
salaire net par mois j'ai fait un petit
calcul ça fait à peu près 13 % des
journalistes donc ça aurait une
incidence non pas de 60 lyon d'économies
mais au maximum d'après mes calculs 8 à
10 millions j'ai repris des chiffres
aujourd'hui et j'ai refait ses petits
calculs donc je trouve que c'est une
économie relativement secondaire et
surtout et surtout si je suis pas contre
une mesure progressive c'est à dire que
les politique de stop and go tout d'un
coup dire on arrête ou alors on fait de
la progressivité dans les abattements
fiscaux mais la faire un seuil de 4000
serait un effet de seuil contre
pleinement contradictoire outre la
rupture d'égalité des personnes vous
savez les personnes qui gagnent plus de
4000 euros dans une rédaction ce sont
des rédacteurs en chef des rédacteurs en
chef adjoints des gens qui ont plus de
50 ans qui ont 30 ans d'expérience et
souvent qui voient leurs évolutions
salariales contenu des entreprises
augmentent et liés à laurent cents et
tout d'un coup en franchissant la barre
des 4000 euros il serait en perte de
revenus nets en perdant cet amendement
donc j'ai un moment il faut aussi tenir
compte des équilibres économiques d'un
secteur et aussi de ce que ce secteur
parce que je rappelle la presse
d'information est un secteur privé mais
secteur privé qui par son pluralisme
remplit une mission de fonction publique
c'est celle justement d'assurer le
pluralisme de la presse donc je pense
que on joue pas avec ce type de niche
opportunément il y a des objectifs il ya
un début de travail de réforme qui a été
fait des aides à la presse et je pense
sincèrement que les aides qui encourage
embaucher des gens de qualité la
question n'est pas de savoir simplement
la qualité d'impression la qualité de
diffusion ou la qualité du marketing
d'un support de presse le premier
élément c'est la qualité et c'est la
richesse de sa rédaction pour cette
raison le groupe écologiste votera
contre cet amendement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président marine est
excellent collègue yvon collin que son
initiative est tout à fait méritoire est
utile
mais en même temps que l'amendement tel
qu'il est libellé peut sans doute se
heurter à certains obstacles et il me
semble que nous avons là un cas type
de notre système
rongé par temps étant d'exception et de
dépenses fiscales en d'autres termes de
niche et nous savons bien que ce système
de niches ne va pas pouvoir durer très
longtemps parce que chacune provient de
démarches professionnelles
corporatives
d'intérêt bien regroupée et qui se sont
fait valoir auprès de la puissance
publique qui est tombé qui ont obtenu
ceci ou cela au fil du temps et ici
s'agissant de nos amis journalistes
il s'agit si je ne me trompe d'un régime
de déduction forfaitaire et
s'il ministre a répondu qu'il peut y
avoir un problème d'égalité devant
l'impôt c'est peut-être que s'agissant
des frais professionnels forfaitaires
quel que soit le niveau de revenu la
création d'une barrière peu
se heurter à cette question de principe
maintenant et si ce n'était pas
un régime de
de calcul forfaitaire
des frais professionnels
mais un autre procédé
il serait possible de distinguer selon
les niveaux de revenus me semble-t-il il
doit y avoir bien des précédents de
régimes fiscaux privilégiés et qui sont
sous plafond de revenus donc à cet égard
je comprends bien la démarche du groupe
du rds ce
monsieur le ministre je profite de cet
amendement pour vous demander si vous
avez réellement l'intention
d'entrer dans une démarche de
plafonnement de la dépense fiscale car
plus on regarde au cas par cas chaque
niche et plus on se convainc qu'il est
impossible de changer quoi que ce soit
et est ce qu'il ne serait pas temps
monsieur le ministre
d'entrer dans une démarche d'évaluation
de la dépense fiscale et de maîtrise
puis de réduction de la dépense fiscale
par plafonnement de ces effets et afin
de mieux gérer le solde des finances
publiques ou alors pensez vous que notre
rôle le soin de nous livrer dans ce
théâtre d'ombrés à ce type de débat qui
se conclut en général de la même façon
par le retrait de l'amendement ou là où
l'on a montré à la fois son souci de la
maîtrise des finances publiques et puis
bien entendu sa compréhension amical
pour la corporation dont il s'agit
merci monsieur de ligier
dit dans ce mini moi enfin cet
amendement ou ce type d'abonnement
reviennent régulièrement tous les ans
concernant la niche fiscale moi je qui
serait je pense qu'il serait quand même
peut-être plus intéressant de ne plus
jamais parler de la niche fiscale des
journalistes non mais à chaque fois ça
revient tous les ans il ya quelques
essais pour voir si on peut y toucher et
puis finalement ben y'a un repli
généralisé puisqu'on a bien compris que
c'était une corporation à laquelle il
fallait pas toucher pour des raisons
diverses et variées on a notre collègue
écologiste qui a donné les siennes pour
donner les leurs bon il est clairement
ça fait 20 ans que jean pas parler de ça
et ça fait 20 ans qu'on recule
systématiquement donc ce qui serait plus
raisonnable c'est qu'on n'en parle plus
jamais et que ce soit quelque chose
d'établi budgétairement qu'il ya une
niche fiscale qui est établi pour cette
catégorie là que peut-être pour d'autres
il vaut mieux toucher à leur avantage
mais que cette catégorie là fait partie
des intouchables puis les choses
seraient claires c'est même plus à avoir
tel ou tel sentiment d'amitié ou pas
amitié c'est comme ça ça fait partie de
notre système social on ne touche pas à
cette niche fiscale et on ne parle plus
merci je vais donc mettre ou un
amendement de monsieur koné il est
retiré il est retiré
après l'article 1er amendement 58 qui le
défend monsieur foucault
oui merci monsieur le président si
munissent mes chers collègues oui avec
cet amendement nous ne pensons pas
monsieur le ministre
que c'est en taxant mettant plus
lourdement à contribution
je dirais celles et ceux et surtout
celles d'ailleurs qui ont mené de pair
vie professionnelle et vie familiale que
l'on parviendra à résoudre les
difficultés budgétaires de l'état il y à
des dépenses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
en regardant d'ailleurs alors nous
pensons que gelé les retraites dont le
montant est supérieur à 1200 euros n'est
pas bonne mesure alors où notamment on
aide le grand patronat à coups de
milliards
alors je le redis
la mesure là qui a été votée
dernièrement palais bourbon de geler les
retraites dont le montant est supérieur
à 1200 euros n'est pas bonne mesure
aujourd'hui je dirais que le problème ce
n'est pas que le niveau des retraites et
progresser plus vite que celui des
salaires mais je dirais bien plus tôt
que les salaires soient aussi bas alors
donc l'objet de cet amendement est
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux ménages
salariés et retraités et singulièrement
les plus modestes et ceux qui n'ont
toujours vécu que du produit de leur
travail bien sûr passe donc le par une
remise en question de dispositions
inéquitable prises récemment comme je
lai indiqué li un instant
et quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur rapporteur général
la vie est négatif sur le président
défavorable c'est un coût d'un peu plus
d'un milliard d'euros en plus c'est un
amendement anti redistributifs donc à
vis des forains s'il y avait du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
j'ai bien conscience qu'on peut
recommencer la loi de finances initiale
donc évidemment le gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement d'ailleurs
vous avez parlé d'une mesure qui n'est
pas dans le texte que nos étudiants que
vous avez parlé d'une mesure sur le pnf
rss avec le gel des pensions
là vous composé de revenir sur une autre
mesure les gens pour rejoindre en
profiter une seconde pour répondre au
président marini
d'ailleurs curieux puisque là on parle
d'une niche en fait
il ya d'autres niches concernant les
pensions qui sont régulièrement mises en
avant par la cour des comptes que qui
est souvent cité ce soir
oui le gouvernement entend plafonner les
niches monsieur le président il l'a fait
lui je crois même que ça a provoqué un
certain émoi sur un certain nombre de
dispositions quand nous avons plafonné à
10000 euros le bénéfice de certaines
niches
le gouvernement a également
fait évoluer
et j'espère que nous pourrons continuer
les dispositifs de défiscalisation sur
l'outre-mer
avec un dispositif que vous connaissez
bien et j'espère que nous pourrons aller
encore plus loin mais nous avons fait
bouger les choses donc oui nous
poursuivrons ne va pas échapper je crois
dans les derniers chiffres publiés que
certes elles n'ont pas diminué les
dépenses fiscales mais n'augmente plus
c'est déjà un fait puisqu'on est je
crois aux alentours de 70 milliards
d'euros sur l'ensemble des niches
fiscales encore faudrait-il s'entendre
sur la signification du mot
de la notion puisque là aussi les
discours sont règle les analyses sont
très controversés pense notamment à
l'abattement pour frais de 10 % pour les
sur les pensions et retraites que la
cour des comptes classe régulièrement
comme la principale niches fiscales
autant les frais réels peuvent se
concevoir sur les frais pendant les
frais professionnels sur un actif oui
autant sur les retraités la cour en tout
cas s il considère que ça constitue de
niches
fiscales il y en a bien d'autres
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas le
gouvernement l'intention de poursuivre
ce plafonnement des niches et de la
dépense fiscale
même avis défavorable en tout cas sur
sur l'amendement raison aussi de son
coût qui vient d'être rappelé par le
faudra pourtant
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
comte
dans monsieur le président monsieur miss
mes chers collègues il n'y a pas de
possibilité de retour de la confiance
sans justice et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
l'article 1 qui va dans le bon sens et
qui a permis de redonner un peu de
pouvoir d'achat ce qui avait été le plus
mis à contribution depuis 2010 en
particulier par les collectifs
budgétaires successifs de la fin du
gouvernement fillon a été une bonne
chose et c'est bien qu'il a été voté
tout à l'heure et le le rapport de notre
rapporteur général montre bien ce que ça
redonne en pouvoir d'achat aux français
qui avait été le plus impacté par ces
mesures
toutefois je profite de l'amendement de
de nos collègues communistes pour réagir
aussi à certaines
prises de position que j'ai entendu tout
à l'heure comme s'il y avait des
français qui paient l'impôt et d'autres
qu'ils ne paient pas tout le monde le
paye car chaque français et chaque
personne qui habite sur notre territoire
et qui a un revenu de son travail est
soumis à des prélèvements obligatoires
cg et impôt sur le revenu tout le monde
le paye csg et c'est une certaine une
quasi flat tax et cette remarque je
souhaite la faire parce que il y a aussi
les comparaisons européennes entre
prélèvements sur le revenu
et quand on regarde notre impôt sur le
revenu il faut bien avoir en tête que ce
dispositif cg plus impôt sur le revenu
que nous avons en france les autres pays
ne l'ont pas et c'est ainsi qu'il faut
faire les comparaisons et c'est la
raison pour laquelle lorsque j'entends
en particulier sur les bancs du groupe
ump qui aurait une bonne partie des gens
qui parce qu'ils ne payent pas l'impôt
sur le revenu ne participerait pas à la
solidarité nationale je m'inscris en
faux et
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure en expliquant
pourquoi la mesure de l'article 1
n'était pas bonne mais au contraire
qu'il fallait donner du pouvoir d'achat
à ce qui était qui paient un peu plus
d'impôts sur le revenu alors j'en
profite parce que quand on regarde ce
qui a été vu les différents amendements
que nous voyons depuis tout à l'heure
montre que cette cette situation c g +
impôt sur le revenu elle ne peut
probablement pas duré très longtemps
parce qu'effectivement voilà on est tous
à essayer de trouver le moyen d'aider
les français les plus fragiles les plus
modestes qui
sont à la lisière de l'impôt sur le
revenu alors que nous avons une bonne
proportion des français qui ne payent
pas l'impôt sur le revenu mais qui paye
de la csg et c'est la raison de mon
intervention parce que il est bien
évident que c'est impossible de faire ça
dans un collectif budgétaire mais si on
veut réellement redonner du pouvoir
d'achat allant semble des français en
particulier aux plus modestes il est
important de lancer cette réflexion sur
une csg qui ne serait plus une quasi
flat tax mais qui aurait une petite
progressivité une progressivité au moins
au début sans entacher sa facilité de
collecte mais qui permettrait aux plus
modestes qui travaillent et qui payent
des prélèvements obligatoires en
conséquence de leur travail de pouvoir
avoir des prélèvements qui sont qu'il
soit progressif et je crois que de cette
manière nous pourrions éviter un certain
nombre d'amendements de niches fiscales
qui montre que notre système est à bout
de souffle je vous remercie
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 58,1 monsieur foucault pardon
excusez moi
oui merci monsieur le président
simplement par rapport aux remarques qui
ont été faites peut-être que il faudra
rappeler les politique d'allègement du
coût du travail et qui notamment ont été
lancés dans des années ont été donnés à
l'automne 93
soit je dirais quelques mois après la
réforme des retraites et notamment avec
la loi quinquennale sur le travail
l'emploi et la formation professionnelle
faut peut-être sans rappeler mais c'est
cette politique n'a jamais cessé de
prendre de la vigueur depuis j'aurais
rappeler que quand même on dépensait à
l'époque le 1 milliards d'euros pour
alléger les supposés charges des
entreprises je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui
cette dépense fiscale atteint mon cher
collègue 30 milliards fallait-il aussi
le dire dans votre intervention 30
milliards d'euros et je dirais que cice
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et l'emploi ne ferait qu'alourdir parce
que il faut regarder ce que 30 milliards
ça ça fait un parent pour subventionner
je dirais peut-être huit cent mille
emplois mal payés je dirais que cela
fait quand même mes chers collègues un
peu cher et peut-être faudrait-il révisé
là encore vos politiques
je dirais que c'est aux moyens
au niveau moyen des pensions d'ailleurs
alors je crois que rétablir la non
imposition des majorations des pensions
est je crois la moindre chose des choses
que nous puissions faire je pourrais
aussi mon cher collègue rappelé les
réformes des retraites à commencer par
celle de balladur en 1993 celle de ce
qu'on a appelé fillon 1 en 2003 et celle
de fillon 02/02/2010 qui elle également
il faut aussi voir les choses au niveau
de l'histoire de l'histoire je dirais
d'un contemporaine qui ont tous tendus à
comprimer le montant des pensions des
classes de population d'ailleurs très
nombreuses celles qui étaient très
expérimentés qui ont quitté d'ailleurs
long du travail au début du 21e siècle
je voulais rappeler ça parce que c'est
important notamment de dire aussi
que sur cette histoire la vérité
commande de dire que sans les réformes
balladur sans les réformes fillon et
autres le montant moyen aura été plus
élevé encore alors je continue à penser
et à dire que là ce qui a été voté
dernièrement au palais bourbon n'est
n'est pas une bonne chose et
ne l'aidera pas à
régler les problèmes budgétaires du pays
c'est pourquoi il faut revenir sur cette
décision cette mauvaise décision qui a
été prise si monsieur le président
monsieur doligé
a pris tout simplement pour dire à notre
collègue que sap a été dit sur les
bandes ump alors peut-être que certains
l'ont pensé sur nos bancs en tout cas
elles n'ont pas exprimé donc je tiens à
vous le préciser deuxièmement vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que
tout le monde paye la paix la csg nom et
un certain nombre de personnes qui
touchent des prestations d'un certain
niveau souvent deux fois le smic dans
mon département je peux vous en citer un
certain nombre qui est à peu près trente
mille personnes tyrosse
oui enfin vous avez des gens qui ne
travaillent pas qui touche deux fois
leurs revenus du travail de ceux qui
travaillent à côté et qui paye le rsa le
smic par bat pas le smic la csg et
l'impôt sur le revenu et y en a d'autres
qui ont des ressources beaucoup plus
importante et qui ne payent rien donc ça
peut parfois choqué aussi donc je
comprends mon collègue tout à l'heure
qui a fait tout justement cette remarque
de dire qu'il ya des personnes qui
devraient peut-être payé quelque chose
et qui ne payent pas actuellement si
vous voulez je vous apporterai un
certain nombre de documents que je ne
tiens pas à rendre public ici
merci je mets donc aux voix l'amendement
58 quels sont ceux qui souhaitent
adopter cet amendement 58
avis contraire
il n'est pas adoptée après l'article 1er
est l'amendement 197 monsieur delattre
il s'agit de rétablir
à dispositif un dispositif qui avait
fait ses preuves pour le pouvoir d'achat
est une des différences si effectivement
ils manifestent entre vos propositions
et les nôtres c'est que cette
proposition est liée à une valeur et la
valeur travail
c'est à dire de faire en sorte que les
gens qui font des heures supplémentaires
avaient un avantage fiscal
et les entreprises
avaient cet immense avantage de pouvoir
adapter leur carnet de commandes à la
situation du moment par rapport au
salaire un peu de souplesse dans un
système dont tout le monde est d'accord
je crois aujourd'hui pour dire qu'il est
quand même assez rigide donc à la fois
l'injection de pouvoir d'achat
intelligente est une façon pour les
entreprises de gérer leurs carnets de
commandes une façon aussi intelligente
ce dispositif était justement dans la
loi tepa vous avez beaucoup critiqué
mais suit 1 9 million de personnes ont
bénéficié huit à neuf millions de
personnes
et quand même je vois le
ce qui a été fait en réalité face aux
frondeurs de l'assemblée nationale pour
faire en sorte que les revenus les plus
modestes échappent à l'impôt sur le
revenu par rapport à 8 ou 9 millions de
personnes et par rapport 3,7 mio qui
sont concernés ça fait quand même un
gros écart est en réalité ça touche
effectivement les classes moyennes et
les classes moyennes ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui travaillent en quoi
il ya eu cinq crises mais la plupart
c'est la moyenne donc nous souhaiterons
nous souhaitons rétablir ce dispositif
naturellement dans le temps dans
l'amendement l'ia la technique
que vous connaissez tous qui a été
reprise mais de vous dire quand vous
nous dites nous défendons les classes
en difficulté les classes à revenu à bas
revenus vous savez il ya plus grand moun
ki vous croient dans les bas revenus les
représentants du parti socialiste aux
dernières élections municipales et
européennes ya moins de 10% les ouvriers
qui votent pour le parti socialiste
alors ce discours savez passe de plus en
plus de moins en moins bien parce qu'il
ya les réalités et une réalité c'est
cuit tout neuf millions de personnes se
sont retrouvées avec des ressources avec
des revenus en nette diminution et que
cela a causé un préjudice certain
d'ailleurs n'y a pas encore quelle il ya
quelques mois nous entendions des
parlementaires de votre groupe dire que
ça a été une belle erreur et bas cette
erreur nous vous donnons l'occasion
messieurs du parti socialiste monsieur
le ministre de pouvoir la réparer alors
vous allez me dire oui mais ça coûte
temps c'est vrai que ça a un coût il est
vrai que si vous aviez voté la
suppression d'articles sera le
financement était presque trouvé mais
puisque vous allez nous dire que vous ne
proposez pas la façon de financer on
peut lancer des pistes première piste la
franchise à eme qui fait partie de nos
amendements un peu plus loin le fameux
jour de carence d'être supprimés ce sont
des mesures à 250 millions et puis si
vous voulez y aller
jusqu'à un milliard d'euros et 500
millions les rythmes scolaires dont la
plupart des mères qu'on se constate
aujourd'hui que ça va être un beau
fiasco à la rentrée prochaine voilà
quelques propositions quelques pistes et
l'occasion
vous est donc donné en votant ses
amendements de rétablir ce qui fut une
erreur il y a deux ans et faire en sorte
d'injecter effectivement à des gens vont
directement dans la population un vrai
pouvoir d'achat si j'étais de soutenir
la croissance
et à vis de la commission le rapporteur
général
l'avis est défavorable monsieur le
président nous avons déjà eu des débats
nourris de plusieurs heures sur cette
question de la fiscalisation
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
et ce soir je veux simplement vous
rappeler que c'est un milliard d'euros
de recettes en moins alors j'ai bien
noté dans l'argumentation utilisé pour
l'amendement que vous considériez que
les mesures de relance du pouvoir
d'achat était insuffisant tant que je
note une nouvelle confirmation de votre
conversion monsieur delattre à la
politique de relance par la consommation
de pouvoir d'achat c'est cette une
innovation ce soir que de constater que
vous avez vraiment changé complètement
votre ligne politique mais après tout
temps les débats de ce genre tout est
possible après tout je comprends qu'on
puisse proposer des choses puis leur
contraire en tout cas bien entendu ici
l'avis est défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
on va pas passer notre temps à ça parce
que le gouvernement n'est pas d'accord
pour revenir sur cette disposition ne
peut pas nous reprocher de changer tout
est politique et parallèlement nous
reprocher de ne pas en changer donc non
ce n'est pas important général l'a dit
qu'ils aient lieu
personne n'empêche les entreprises de
s'adapter en ayant recours à des heures
supplémentaires et où très peu de
limitation avec les annualisation et
tous les dispositifs qui sont prévues
votre argument sur la flexibilité des
effectifs pour répondre et pour pouvoir
s'adapter aux évolutions du marché du
travail ne tiennent pas seul instant pas
un instant sur le reste on a un débat de
fond sur le fait de savoir si on doit ou
pas
encourager des heures supplémentaires
plutôt que l' embauche tout a été dit
sur les effets d'aubaine sur
les les peu d'heures supplémentaires qui
ont été
enregistrées en plus au moment de
l'adoption de cette mesure qui est un
coup non seulement ce sénateur
je pense que ce chiffre j'ai pas fait
vérifier mais sous-évalué par rapport à
ce que j'ai en tête mais qui a également
un coût sur les cotisations sociales
puisque font appel que mais on est 6 la
pfr qui avait également une exonération
de charges sur les heures
supplémentaires
donc vraiment il est totalement
différent
si monsieur de la ddt pour explications
de vote
le fait qu'on propose quelques
amendements ne veut pas dire que nous
sommes totalement changé de stratégie ça
n'a rien à voir est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous pouvez vous avez depuis deux
ans combien de chômeurs en plus monsieur
repose en général
quatre cent cinquante mille chômeurs en
plus est ce que ça ne vous amène pas les
uns les autres à réfléchir et nous
savons et on vous écoute et nous
partageons parfois une certaine analyse
de dire qu'il faut les choses il faut
les deux il faut être capable de
relancer
la consommation et la relance est là et
les moyens d'investir nous avons aussi
des propositions pour investir quand sur
les entreprises dont vous nous parler
abondamment qu'on doit retrouver la
compétitivité mais nous sommes d'accord
là dessus nous vous proposons aussi des
amendements par exemple nous vous
proposons depuis des gens moins un an de
retirer la non déductibilité fiscale des
intérêts des entreprises pour investir
alors que dans ce pays il n'y a pas de
fonds dédiés à la halle aux
investissements des entreprises que 90 %
des pme pmi ont affaire en réalité ont
besoin de prêts bancaires vous avez osé
mettre une ingénierie financière aussi
désastreuses pour les investissements
des entreprises donc les investissements
nous avons aussi des amendements nous
avons aussi politique mais ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant que sur un certain
nombre de sujets nous proposons des
dispositifs différents des vôtres nous
on le lit à une valeur qui la valeur
travail pour la relance
nous sommes aussi sur d'autres sujets
comme comme les investissements des
collectivités territoriales vous nous
dites vous parlez d investissement vous
allez retirer 11 milliards aux
collectivités territoriales et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui gèrent des
collectivités monsieur rapporteur
général savent très bien que ce sont les
investissements dont seront les
premières victimes quand nous disons
tout ceci est surtout cela nous avons
des amendements nous n'avons pas que des
amendements orienté vers la relance de
la consommation nous disons qu'il ya
deux moteurs l'investissement des
entreprises et la consommation
si monsieur colin
oui monsieur le président
colin la parole et lui seul merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues plusieurs
membres du groupe rdse avait déposé lors
de l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2014 un amendement identique à
celui ci à celui de monsieur delattre
par conséquent nous confirmerons ce soir
par notre vote de novembre dernier en
soutenant très majoritairement cet
amendement comme nous l'avons exprimée
en discussion générale nous appelons
ardemment une refonte globale de notre
système fiscal afin de le rendre plus
lisible plus juste en effet si un
système fiscal
qu'on peut qualifier de idéal
défiscaliser heures supplémentaires peut
sembler injuste
en l'état actuel de notre fiscalité de
notre économie il en va tout autrement
il est évident que la pression fiscale
est aujourd'hui très élevé sans doute
trop élevé pour une majorité de
contribuables et pas seulement les plus
favorisés nous avons entendre leur
incompréhension face à une augmentation
brutale et parfois extrêmement
importante leur imposition avait des
revenus identiques à l'année précédente
nous pensons que sur un tel sujet il est
impératif de savoir faire preuve de
pragmatisme et sortir du discours
idéologiques fondées sur des principes
trop éloignée de la réalité vécue par un
grand nombre de français c'est pourquoi
il nous paraît indispensable de
préserver un certain nombre de ménages
d'une charge fiscale trop lourde en
exonérant à nouveau des heures
supplémentaires d'impôt sur le revenu et
de cotisations sociales
cette mesure nous semble-t-il est une
nécessité pour encourager la reprise
économique qui s'amorce à peine en
soutenant le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
moteur de la croissance
merci merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
cet amendement
197 et je suis saisi d'un demandes de
scrutins publics par le groupe ump nous
allons donc procéder au scrutin public
non
le scrutin est ouvert
la question
n'est pas là
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos et nous allons procéder à son
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 sans cesse
sur l'amendement 197 nombre de votants
300 ce nombre de suffrages exprimés
290 pour l'adoption 152 contre 138 le
sénat a adopté l'amendement
après l'article 1er est l'amendement
sens de rectifier monsieur colin
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit à
nouveau mes chers collègues dans
l'amendement qui a déjà été adopté par
notre haute assemblée dans le cadre du
projet de votre finances pour 2014
cet amendement vise à corriger
l'injustice que constitue la suppression
du bénéfice de la demi part fiscale
supplémentaire
accordé aux personnes veuves cette demi
part été supprimée par la précédente
majorité pour les veufs et veuves qui
ont élevé leurs enfants seuls pendant
moins de 50 aujourd'hui l'article 195 du
code général des impôts ne concerne en
effet que les contribuables veuf qui ont
je cite supporter à titre exclusif ou
principal la charge d'un ou plusieurs
enfants pendant au moins cinq années au
cours desquelles il vivait seul or ce
seuil de 5 ans nous semble injustifié
mais aussi injuste c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons de les supprimer en
adoptant cet amendement qui rétablit la
demi part fiscale pour toutes les
personnes veuves voilà le sens de ces
abonnements que je vous proposerai sur
deux si monsieur colin quel est l'avis
de la commission sur rapporteur général
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues l'amendement qui vient nous
est proposé pour pose de de restaurer la
demi part des veuves telle qu'elle
existait auparavant c'est à dire sans la
condition des cinq ans et alors il nous
semble que dans le contexte budgétaire
actuel il n'est pas raisonnable de
restaurer un avantage fiscal accordé à
vie ou personnes vivant seules même si
celles ci n'ont pas assumé la charge
effective de leurs enfants et bien
longtemps après le départ de ces
derniers et dans ces conditions nous
avons noté que le gouvernement a fait le
choix de concentrer les aides sur les
familles ayant effectivement des enfants
à charge par exemple en revalorisant de
25% les aides aux familles
monoparentales dans le cadre du plfss
2014 et dans ces conditions
je demande le retrait de cet amendement
du fait donc que le bénéfice de la demi
part des personnes neuf est dorénavant
conditionnée au fait d'avoir assumé la
charge de famille pendant cinq ans c'est
une condition raisonnable nous at il
semblé qui ne remet pas en cause
l'esprit est la vocation du dispositif
donc je suggère le retrait sinon je
mettrais un avis défavorable de la
commission des finances
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui gouvernement
rejoint l'analyse du rapporteur général
c'est un débat qui est connue qui a déjà
eu lieu
dispositif était institué de façon
progressive à partir de 2009 mais porte
encore ses effets jusque actuellement
d'ailleurs nous sommes à la dernière
année et donc le gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement j'en
profite pour dire par avance que compte
tenu de l'adoption de l'amendement
précédent le gouvernement demandera une
seconde délibération
à l'issue de l'examen de la première
partie du présent projet de loi de
finances rectificative
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement sans de rectifier quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
on va le faire par an assis debout quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
un amendement 115 rectifié qu'à terre
qui le présente ce monsieur le comte je
vous en prie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 200 du code général des impôts
prévoit une réduction d'impôt sur le
revenu égale à 70 % de leur montant les
sommes versées dans la limite de 20 % du
revenu imposable à une association de
financement électoral mandataire
financier d'un candidat dont les
cotisations versées aux partis et
groupements politiques par
l'intermédiaire de leurs mandataires
si au cours de la dernière année
les
nouvelles concernant le financement de
la vie politique ce qui a été marquant
en particulier c'est le sarkothon dont
on peut estimer qu'il a été un une
recette pour l'état de l'ordre de 5
millions d'euros compte tenu des
dispositions précédentes du code général
des impôts alors
sur la base de cette constatation
quand on regarde l'ensemble des
dispositions existantes par rapport aux
financements et contrôle des comptes des
partis politiques nous constatons que
les partis politiques doivent avoir des
comptes certifiés par deux commissaires
aux comptes que ils doivent respecter
des lettres des dépôts de leurs comptes
avant la fin du premier semestre de
l'année suivant l'exercice
c'est à dire qu'au 1er juillet la
commission de contrôle nationale de
contrôle et de financement d
des finances des financements politiques
est susceptible de constater si les
obligations légales en matière de
certification des comptes et de dépôt
des comptes sont effectivement fait par
les partis politiques
à l'initiative
de gaëtan gorce l'année dernière lors de
la loi sur la transparence dans la vie
politique à un amendement sur à
l'article 17 à envisager la possibilité
a donc permis la l'impôt donc signalé
que si un parti politique ne déposaient
pas assez ses comptes dans les délais et
que les comptes n'étaient pas certifiées
alors il y avait une sanction qui était
la non possibilité l'année suivante
l'année suivante donc à partir dans une
quelque chose qu'on constate le 1er
juillet l'année suivante à partir du 1er
janvier eh bien les les dons et
cotisations n'étaient pas déductible
pour les personnes qui effectuent et ses
dons toutefois je constate qu il y a six
mois de délai d'une certaine manière de
grâce où en fait on peut on a le temps
de compenser ce qui pourra ne plus plus
de plus être fait l'année suivante et
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
amendement a vocation à préciser les
choses de manière à ce que à partir du
moment où l'obligation légale de dépôt
des comptes et l'obligation décale
d'avoir des comptes certifiés par deux
commissaires aux comptes et constaté
enfin constater qu'on n'a pas fait au
1er juillet de l'année suivant
l'exercice alors à partir de cette date
et jusqu'à la fin de l'année suivante le
parti en cause ne pourra pas bénéficier
bénéficier ses donateurs et ses
cotisants d'une exemption fiscale prévue
à l'article 200 du code général des
impôts c'est l'objet de cette
proposition qui va dans le sens de
contraindre les partis politiques le
mieux possible et le plus justement
possible au respect de la loi je vous
remercie merci quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur marc
et viennent sur le président j'avais
proposé à la commission des finances
un avis commission m'avait suivi mais je
crois qu'une modification depuis je vais
demander le retrait de l'amendement dont
l'esprit me semblait satisfait par
l'article 17 la loi du 11 octobre 2013
relative à la transparence de la vie
publique
mais
la version rectifiée de votre amendement
chers collègues prévoit que la
suspension de la réduction d'hyères
serait effective à compter du 1er
juillet de l'année en cours et si j'ai
bien compris jusqu'au 31 décembre de
l'année suivante soit à total de 18 mois
au lieu de 12
permet ainsi de combler la faille de six
mois durant laquelle le parti pouvait
continuer à bénéficier de réductions
alors dans ces conditions et compte tenu
de cet élément nouveau peut-être le
gouvernement serait-il à même de nous
éclairer sur ce point particulier ceux
qui me conduiraient à ce moment-là a
suggéré un avis qui pourrait être
différent de celui que nous avions émis
qui était une demande de retrait
monsieur le ministre si vous pouviez
nous éclairer un peu sur ce cet aspect
technique de l'amendement
merci quelle est donc la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui le gouvernement vous remercie ce
sénateur d'avoir posé cette question et
qu'il va nous permettre de préciser
quelle est la législation actuellement
en vigueur
il est vrai qu'à certain nombre
d'événements
agite
légitimement l'opinion
et
j'ai entendu ou lu ça dans deux
déclarations disant que
ceux qui ne sont pour l'instant que des
soupçons en tout cas des éléments qui
interpellent
et qui ont outre une affaire que non la
justice est saisie
qui ont conduit un candidat à la
présidence de la république à ne pas
bénéficier du remboursement de ses frais
de campagne
j'ai lu ici ou là des déclarations qui
consistait à dire que cela n'avait rien
coûté à l'état au contraire je vais dire
que compte tenu des nouvelles évolutions
de ce dossier effectivement se pose la
question
du coup pour l'état qui certes n'a pas
eu à rembourser
les frais de campagne du candidat suite
à décision du conseil constitutionnel
mais néanmoins l'état à supporter deux
tiers
des dons en tout cas certainement une
partie significative de deux tiers des
dons ont été versés à partis politiques
qui s'est substitué selon les
informations qui sont aujourd'hui public
en termes de remboursement des frais de
campagne alors
ceci pour pour dire qu'il ya un vrai
sujet
maintenant sur le fond votre amendement
je considère qu'il est satisfait
aux bémols près de la date de mise en
oeuvre de l'impossibilité pour un parti
politique qui pour une raison ou une
autre tir soit n'aurait pas déposé dans
les délais soit n'aurait pas pu faire
certifier ses comptes par un expert
comptable par des commissaires aux
comptes
perdrait le droit à pouvoir faire
bénéficier ses généreux donateurs de la
réduction fiscale
actuellement c'est le cas puisque vous
l'avez rappelé c'est à l'initiative
d'ailleurs un amendement de votre
commission des finances que l'article 17
de la loi
durand octobre 2013 complète l'article
11-7 de la loi du 11 mars 1988 pardon de
cette précision mais elle doit figurer
au procès verbal
et suite à cet amendement qui a été
adoptée par le parlement
lorsque la commission constate un
manquement aux obligations comptables
prévues par cet article à savoir
soit les comptes n'ont pas été déposées
soit l'obligation de tenir une
comptabilité certifié n'a pas été
inspectés à ce moment-là à compter de
l'année suivante le parti politique ne
peut plus vous suggérer que on prenne en
compte cette disposition à partir du
moment où la commission nationale de
cinq jours un nom compliqué commission
nationale de contrôle des comptes des
financements du parti politique a
prononcé le manquement de ce parti à 21
ans ce moment là il n'y aurait plus
droit à réduction ceci pose un problème
de rétroactivité puisque les
certificats qui donne lieu à déduction
fiscale de son produit en général par
les partis ou les associations de
financement qu'en fin d'année et ne
prennent pas en compte le moment de la
date de versement en clair si le parti
étaient des labellisés
mettons au 1er juillet comme vous
l'évoquez que le don ait lieu avant le
1er juillet ou après le 1er juillet il
donnera lieu à la production d'un même
certificat sans trahir de secret il est
par exemple son nombre de situations où
les versements sont mensuelles
par des systèmes de prélèvements et
donne lieu en fin d'année à la
production d'un seul relevé qui prend en
compte que l'ensemble de l'année donc
techniquement cela paraît très difficile
et deuxièmement ça poserait problème
d'une espèce de rétroactivité d'ailleurs
il est clair que il ne pourrait pas y
avoir
d'ignorance du donateur puisque un
décret du 26 juin 2014 prévoit je cite
que le reçu délivré par un mandataire
d'un parti au mouvement politique au
titre des fonds perçus l'année suivant
le constat par la commission d'un
manquement du parti ou groupement
politique concerné aux obligations un
dois préciser que le thon ou la
cotisation consenti à son profit ne peut
ouvrir droit à la réduction d'impôt
prévue à l'article 3 de l'article 200 du
code général des impôts assis les
contribué à concernés s'il y avait un
manquement l'année suivante serait
pleinement informée du fait qu'ils ne
peuvent bénéficier d'aucun avantage
fiscal donc je pense que votre
amendement pose des problèmes techniques
et mais par contre qu'il est satisfait
par l'amendement que vous aviez adopté à
l'initiative de votre commission des
finances qui rend bien inéligible à la
déduction fiscale certes à partir de
l'année suivant le entre guillemets
délit
je pense qu'il serait techniquement
compliqué et puis qui serait une forme
de rétroactivité qui ce requin donc
aurait été fait en ignorant le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de déduction fiscale
ch poserait un problème déontologique je
crois que il ya lieu de s'en tenir aux
dispositions existantes mais encore une
fois votre amendement montre bien que il
faut être très rigoureux et qu' il se
pourrait que ce qui s'est produit et que
tout le monde a en tête puisse avoir eu
un coût par l'état avant les
investigations pour l'état pardon
investigations cours montreront si c'est
le cas ou non donc je vous proposerai
plutôt de retirer cet amendement à
défaut jean préconiserait lorgé merci
d'amendement est retirée monsieur le
comte
monsieur le président je
je vais je vais le retirer à la demande
du ministre
toutefois
sur effectivement je souhaite tout de
même précisé qu'il n'est pas totalement
satisfait vous l'avez bien signalé il ya
quand même cette
différence de date c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où le 30 juin les
obligations légales d'un parti politique
n'ont pas été n'ont pas été respectées
il y a encore six mois pendant lesquels
le parti peut non seulement recevoir
mais dire attention l'année prochaine
j'aurai plus donc donner moi cette année
et que de ce point de vue le décret du
28 juin 2014 qui met en application les
différentes dispositions de la loi sur
la transparence qui ont été votées et
qui
traitait du cadre d'une part des micro
partis et d'autre part de ce point de
vue là signale bien que les reçus
doivent indiquer la date et la manière
dont avec laquelle le les versements été
fait donc règlement par chèque espèces
carte bancaire virement ou prélèvement
automatique et par conséquent dans
l'article 20 de ce décret on fixe on
précise bien que les reçus doit voir une
date et qu'on peut tracer les paiements
et par conséquent il est tout à fait
possible de savoir si les paiements ont
été faits avant le 30 juin ou après le
30 juin et si une personne souhaite
verser un don ou une cotisation un parti
politique il me semble que il devrait
être au minimum informé de la manière
dont ce parti rempli ses obligations
légales en matière de financement de la
vie politique donc si je retire cet
amendement c'est plus parce que le
décret date de quelques jours que
l'amendement a été rectifié quatre fois
qu' il n'y a pas eu peut-être
suffisamment des changes mais je reste
persuadé que de ce point de vue là les
dispositions légales actuelles ne sont
pas suffisantes car il ya six mois deux
trous qui permettent de prévoir à
l'avance l'année où on aurait on sera
sanctionné et je ne pense pas qu'ils
aient de rétroactivité au contraire j'ai
fait vraiment attention dans
l'amendement à ne pas sanctionner des
campagnes électorales
parce que là pour le coup ça se passe au
préalable mais voilà je le retire d'une
certaine manière compte tenu de la
précipitation dans lequel tout ça c'est
fait mais en étant convaincus qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'il faudra prochainement
corriger si l'amendement est donc retiré
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 106
rectifié monsieur colin
oui monsieur le président monsieur miss
p chers collègues cet amendement
constitue un amendement d'appel pour
alerter le gouvernement sur la situation
particulièrement préoccupante d'un
secteur à la fois essentiel pour notre
économie aussi pour la solidarité
notamment inter générationnelle dans
notre pays je veux parler des services à
la personne
si la solution que nous proposons n'est
peut-être pas la plus appropriée nous en
appelons gouvernement sur le ministre
pour trouver une issue à ce que nous
considérons comme une urgence je
rappelle que le secteur des services à
la personne représentent plus d'un
million d'emplois
comme d'autres il a été durement touchée
par la crise économique et en 2011 le
nombre d'heures d'emploi à domicile
rémunérés par les particuliers a baissé
pour la première fois de 1 8%
de surcroît plusieurs mesures comme la
hausse de la tva et celle des charges
sociales conduisent à une recrudescence
de l'activité non déclarée dans ce
secteur pour éviter le développement du
travail au noir que certaines études de
chiffres quand même à 12% et permettre
le développement des services à la
personne déclaré notre amendement
propose donc d'exclure les réductions
d'impôts accordées au titre de l'emploi
de salariés à domicile du plafonnement
global des niches fiscales je remercie
de m'avoir écouté je vous propose d'être
décidemment no mercy quel avis de la
commission sur la porte en général
la commission a
émis une demande de retrait pour cet
amendement
cet amendement qui vise à exclure les
services à la personne du plafond global
des 10000 euros par an dont peuvent
bénéficier les foyers fiscaux ti des
différentes dépenses fiscales
pourquoi et bien parce que simplement
nous avons noté
que s'il y a bien aujourd'hui nécessité
indéniablement d'apporter un coup de
pouce aux services à la personne
le gouvernement s'est engagé par la voix
du ministre ici présents je les écoutais
à l'assemblée nationale
le 28 mai dernier enfin je les écoutais
dans la petite lucarne qui nous
indiquait que le gouvernement
réfléchissait d'ores et déjà à un geste
en faveur des salariés à domicile et
nous semble donc c'est dans le cadre
d'une prochaine loi de finances comme il
avait prévu je crois que cette question
pourrait être examinée et
nous avons aussi noté chers collègues
ils vont cola que le dispositif que vous
proposez ne paraît pas totalement
équitable dans la mesure où il profite
d'abord aux foyers aisés qui exploite
déjà de nombreuses niches fiscales et
sont touchés par le plafond donc dans la
tente du débat budgétaire de l'automne
je vous suggère de retirer pour
l'instant cet amendement
merci quel est l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à votre
amendement l'état pour plusieurs raisons
tout à l'heure on parlait de plafonner
les niches là on est en train de parler
de l'aider plafonné est un peu
contradictoire
deuxièmement vous savez qu'il y à des
plafonds déjà individuelle de chacun des
types d'emploi et salariés à domicile
par exemple les salariés à domicile pour
le ménage ou la garde d'un enfant pour
un couple avec un enfant le montant
maximum de l' avantage fiscal et de 6750
euros
il est égal au plafond de 10000 euros
dans certaines situations très
particulières liées à l' invalidité pour
les frais de garde des jeunes enfants
le montant maximum davantage fiscal est
fixé par 11 cents à 1150 euros par
enfant à charge ce qui veut dire que on
n'atteint pas le plafond des 10000 euros
avec cette seule utilisation delà de la
déduction au titre des salariés à
domicile donc je pense pas que ce soit
ce qui peut limiter le recours à des
heures de salariés à domicile ou l'avait
d'ailleurs dit vous-même dans la
présentation de votre amendement
d'autres sujets je vais pas les répéter
ici j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
plusieurs fois
peuvent intervenir
des autres avantages sont conservés et
je dois eu l'occasion de vous dire que
le niveau de la réduction de charges qui
est actuellement 75 centimes de l'heure
par heure de salariés
pardon de partie pour les particuliers
employeurs est fixée par décret donc
pourrait évoluer dans un prochain décret
en fonction de l'avancement
effectivement des questions de
financement notamment au plf rss puisque
cela concerne des questions de charges
sociales nous dans la tente je vous
proposerai plutôt de retirer cet
amendement du gouvernement est bien
conscient du problème et as-tu appris à
son nombre d'orientations sur le sujet
que j'espère qu'ils les confirmera
prochainement merci l'amendement retirer
monsieur colin il est retiré après
l'article 1er amendement 119 rectifié
monsieur présent marini
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je rappelle ici le dispositif
de limitation de la déductibilité des
charges financières à l'assiette de
l'impôt sur les sociétés
dont nous parlait notamment tout à
l'heure notre collègue delattre
sera beau de caractère général n'est
toutefois pas applicable aux charges
financières afférentes aux biens acquis
ou construits dans le cadre d'une
convention de service public de
concession de travaux publics de
contrats de partenariat afin de ne pas
pénaliser l'investissement dans les
infrastructures et d'éviter que
l'augmentation du coup tu ne soit
reporté sur la personne publique
concédantes c'est à dire sur les usagers
et je crois me souvenir que notre
commission des finances avait amendé
le dispositif
proposé par le gouvernement en ce qui
concerne cette question de la
déductibilité des charges financières au
titre de l'impôt sur les sociétés est
l'exception que j'ai rappelé est
également applicable aux holdings dont
l'unique objet est la détention de
titres de sociétés intervenant dans ces
domaines s'agissait de s'assurer que
d'exception était neutre du point de vue
de l'organisation capitalistique des
sociétés de travaux publics ou de
service public en question toutefois la
formulation retenue
apparaît à mon sens trop restrictive car
seuls les holding détenant des sociétés
exclusivement concessionnaires voire
leurs charges financières exonérés si
elles détiennent des titres de sociétés
non concernés et ceci de manière
accessoire rapporte à leur vocation
principale leurs charges financières se
voient appliquer le rabot y compris pour
celles d'entre elles qui sont pourtant
bien afférentes à des concessions de
travaux publics ou de service public
voici les raisons pour lesquelles mes
chers collègues je vous soumets cet
amendement merci monsieur le président
vis de la commission sur la poteau
général
bien
je crois monsieur le président chers
collègues qu'il s'agit là
de traiter d'un problème spécifique
rencontrées par certains opérateurs
seraient d'ailleurs utiles que le
gouvernement puisse apporter son
éclairage
bon et donc je vais demander l'avis du
gouvernement car sept ans prévoit
d'étendre une exonération qui me
semble-t-il serait assez coûteuse d'au
moins plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros ce qui n'est pas négligeable
et qui serait difficile à mettre en
oeuvre parce qu' il serait en
particulier difficile d'identifier le
lien entre les charges de la société
mère et les biens acquis
ou construits par la société fille et
dans ces conditions je pense que
l'éclairage du gouvernement nous serait
fort utile je demande à vis du
gouvernement
merci quelle est donc la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
wallon n'est pas favorable à cet
amendement en l'état
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
cette
exception à la règle de la limitation
déductibilité des charges notamment
financière des entreprises le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas y apporter
de dérogation il y en a d'ailleurs eu
très
minime qui a été fait sur une affaire de
stocks à rotation lente dans certaines
industries notamment agroalimentaires
après une vaste discussion
dans l'autre chambre du parlement qui
d'ailleurs montre
une efficacité extrêmement limité parce
qu'on avait dit c'est quelque chose qui
ne tourne pas et par contre il ya une
disposition qui fait que les délégations
de service public les partenariats privé
public privé bénéficient s'ils ont été
conclus antérieurement à la date enfin
la date de l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi de finances en question d'une
dérogation et non pas à l'avenir là
encore ça a fait l'objet d'une
discussion assez vive entre
gouvernements de l'époque et la majorité
à l'assemblée nationale je suis bien
placé pour vous le dire
c'était finalement un compromis avait
été trouvé entre le tout ou rien sur les
partenariats public privé les dsp on
avait dit ok pour celles qui sont en
cours mais pas pour les autres vous
souhaitez apporter par voie législative
une réponse à une situation dont on peut
s'interroger légitimement comme l'a fait
le rapporteur général sur la pertinence
ou pas vous propose plutôt de laisser
l'administration travaillé sur les
quelques cas qui pourraient qui pourrait
être rencontrer et voir s'il y a lieu de
légiférer ou pas aussi
l'interprétation de la législation en
vigueur pourrait permettre de donner une
réponse pertinente au souci légitime que
vous venez d'évoquer donc je propose
plutôt de retirer cet amendement le cas
échéant si aucune solution n'était
trouvée si le les quelques problèmes
existants justifier d'une modification
législative je vous propose que la
remettent à plus tard notamment loi de
finances initiale voilà monsieur
président marini ce que je souhaitais
dire par rapport à un amendement
merci monsieur présent marine et le
président je remercie vivement le
ministre de sa réponse eu très très
argumenté j'en conviens et effectivement
il y a lieu d'attendre et de voir si
l'administration peut en examinant les
cas qui lui seraient soumis et tenir
compte
de ce que j'avais souhaité je vais
souhaité exposer à l'aide de cet
amendement dans l'immédiat bien sûr je
le retire
merci l'amendement est donc retiré mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance je vous donne la lecture de
l'ordre du jour du mardi 8 juillet 2014
à 9h30 pour les questions orales à 14h30
et le soir pour la suite de ce projet de
loi de finances rectificatif pour 2014
monsieur le président rennais mais
simplement rappelé aux membres de la
commission des finances que nous nous
réunissons demain à 9 heures pour
remettre quelques amendements dans la
machine
merci la séance est levée
c'est un territoire qui fait souvent la
une de l'actualité pour ces
affrontements entre bandes rivales mais
qu'y at il derrière les chiffres de la
petite délinquance et qui sont ces
bandes de jeunes si souvent montré du
doigt une enquête qui bouscule les idées
reçues sur la banlieue enfin selon la
police gendron toujours raison
les bandes le quartier mois samedi à
15h15 sur public sénat
printemps 2007 l'union nationale des
étudiants de france fête son centième
anniversaire à lille
tout le monde est là syndicats et partis
depuis longtemps les gouvernements
prennent des coups de colère
universitaire qui les oblige si souvent
a reculé
et depuis la libération l'unef a presque
toujours joué un rôle déterminant dans
le mouvement dans la négociation
m
l'unef est ancré à gauche ces anciens
dirigeants sont nombreux au parti
socialiste
les élections présidentielles approchent
2 million et demi d'étudiants pèse lourd
l'unef le cese interpelle tous les
candidats
les batailles à venir seront rudes mais
les étudiants à leur syndicat ont montré
au cours de l'histoire qu'il pouvait
faire preuve d'une incroyable capacité à
résister pour améliorer les conditions
de vie des étudiants
on se vante 40 paris
le général de gaulle est à londres
depuis des mois
ce jour là des étudiants des lycéens
manifestent sur les champs-elysées
c'est le premier acte de résistance sur
le sol français on l'a oublié
une partie des tracts qui circulent a
été imprimé dans les locaux clandestins
de l'unef
ils sont 3000 à braver l'occupant des
communistes des chrétiens des gaullistes
le bilan est lourd des centaines
d'arrestations des dizaines de blessés
des disparus
certains sont morts d'autres se cachent
avant de rejoindre le maquis
en 44 le dirigeant de l'unaf gilbert-dru
est assassiné à lyon par la gestapo son
engagement était personnelle
le syndicat lui s'est limité à condamner
le service du travail obligatoire c'est
tout
à la libération les étudiants résistants
vont devoir défendre leurs syndicats que
le conseil national de la résistance a
décidé des purées
vérité oblige à dire les collabos était
très rare d'un autre que l'essence à
l'unef on ne connaît pas
l'unef a été beaucoup plus les reproches
que nous avons fait nous les groupes de
résistants après guerre
c'était plutôt de ne pas s'être engagé
agent de liaison dans le maquis de la
loire paul bouchet prend en main l'unef
à lyon il est soutenu par un noyau
d'anciens de l'armée secrète au congrès
de 44 les lyonnais insuffler l'esprit de
résistance dans les débats en entrée la
l'âge et il y avait eu 300 camarades
étudiants tombé de 1939 à 1945 pour
l'honneur étudiants pour la patrie
française et pour la liberté du monde
c'était ça c'est pas que simplement
d'environ 40 c'était tout c'était
surtout la glagla les gens qui étaient
tombés pendant l'occupation
il faut comprendre que le rendez-vous de
l'unef tel rendez vous plus large de la
partie de la jeunesse avec 1